this is Jocko podcast number 210 with
echo Charles and me Jocko willing
good evening echo good evening and also
joining us tonight is Dave Burke good
evening Dave good evening and the last
time that Dave was on we discussed
marine corps doctrinal publication three
Taquan tactics which starts with a line
that reads this publication is about
winning in combat which is an
outstanding way to start off any
publication of any kind and we actually
ended up covering that manual on a
series of four podcast 187 188 189 and
190 and that definitely is an
outstanding manual when it comes to
winning in combat for sure it explains
the concepts it reveals the underlying
philosophies and there are other
doctrinal publications from the Marine
Corps on operations and on strategy and
on campaigning and there's manuals on
intelligence and expeditionary
operations and logistics and planning
and command and control there's a manual
on the marine rifle squad they got
manuals for everything there's even a
Marine Corps warfighting publication of
three tack 15.1 called machine guns and
machine gun gunnery which is a 406 page
manual by the way 406 page manual this
is the manual where you learn that quote
this machine gun supports both the
offense and defense it provides the
heavy volume of close accurate and
continuous fire support necessary to
suppress and destroy enemy
fortifications vehicles and personnel in
support of an attack the long-range
closed defensive and final protective
fires delivered by this gun
I'm an integral part of the unit's
defensive fires so they're going deep
they're going deep on machine guns and
machine gun gunnery is there a title of
any book in the world that has a gun in
it more times I don't know of any it
also shows you exactly how to fire from
the bipod with a 240 Gulf so firing from
the bipod when firing from the bipod the
rear sight is raised assume a prone
position behind the gun with the right
shoulder into the weapon the right hand
grasps the pistol grip and manipulates
the trigger place the left hand on the
comb of the stock palm down with the
cheek resting lightly against the cover
and or the left hand both hands exert a
firm steady pressure to the rear during
aiming and firing
unlike the tripod the bipod mount is
relatively unstable elbows and upper
torso may move a good sight picture must
be regained before firing each burst so
we're getting details there's no there's
not much room for interpretation we're
getting the instruction that we need by
the way the army also has a manual for
machine gunners the fm3 TAC 22.6 a
crew-served machine gun which doesn't
actually cover the 50 Cal it's got
another manual for that doesn't cover
the MA deuce but it's still 430 pages
long so they are not playing around and
by the way we salute all the machine
gunners out there for what you do
laying down that suppressive fire and we
understand that manuals get granular and
show us how to do a specific job now the
leader the the military does have
leadership manuals as well and we've
covered a bunch of them and they are
solid in explaining some of the
principles of leadership but I always
wanted something that was more granular
the more detailed more specific for
leadership
something that explained the actual
strategies and tactics to be used when
leading people the little maneuvers that
you make up and down the chain of
command and so so I wrote a book and
it's called leadership strategy and
tactics field manual and it is released
January 14th 2020 and I wanted to review
it for you all right as it comes out to
highlight what the book is how you can
use it and what the book will do for you
as a leader and since I work with Dave
all the time first in the battle of
Ramadi and now at echelon front and
since he's been on the podcast multiple
times and since he listens to the
podcasts and since he was the first
person that I gave this book to to read
I figured it made sense to have him on
here so he could help me introduce the
book to the world so Dave thanks for
coming on man good to be here man
you got a couple versions you got the
early versions I did I got a couple
early versions yeah I was just I was
just spilling thoughts on the page like
yes this this this and then I started to
formulate them into categories and
eventually turned them into this so
leadership strategy and tactics we're
gonna go to the book and I kind of had
to do a little bit of explanation here
in the beginning of the book just to
explain sort of what's going on here who
I am what well it goes like this Who am
I to try and teach leaders how to lead
where did I learn leadership much of my
leadership education was luck
I say luck because there were a few
fortunate coincidences that gave me the
right frame of mind the right teachers
and the right opportunities to learn one
of the ways I was lucky and that made me
focus on leadership was the fact that I
wasn't really that naturally talented at
anything in particular as a little kid I
wasn't the fastest or strongest or
smartest I was never great at shooting a
basketball kicking a soccer ball or
throwing a baseball I didn't win any
races or
a shelf of trophies and ribbons from
sports my report card was never
exceptional either I might have done
well in a class if I was interested but
I usually wasn't and my grades reflected
that I was average across the board
coming out strong coming out strong
average across the board that's where
we're at and this is where it kind of
ties in so even from a young age I
needed to get others with more talent
and more skill to do what I needed them
to do I needed to lead of course I
didn't think of it as leadership I just
thought I was making things happen in
contributing by getting people to work
together to support one another as we
moved toward a common mission now maybe
that mission was building a fort in the
woods or planning a mock military
assault with squirt guns on another
group of friends and this is real like
III remember when I was when it was time
to build a fort when it was time to
organize an assault on some other group
I'd be like all right hey this is what
we need to do and that's cuz I knew that
little Johnny could run faster than me
I knew that Billy could scale that wall
better than I could but I could take a
step back and say okay this is what this
is how we should do it this would be the
best way to build this sport this is
what we need to do so whatever the task
was I generally found myself giving
direction to people who were stronger
faster or otherwise more capable than I
was that seemed to be where I could help
the most and the one area in which I
could perform with a higher level of
competency I also always had a
rebellious streak which I think all but
I think everyone has I think well I
shouldn't say that I think many people
cuz how much of a rebellious streak did
Kyle carpenter have like he didn't have
much of a rebellious streak I mean he
had enough to join the Marine Corps but
when you listen to him he's like yeah he
wasn't he wasn't looking to rebel he was
just just on the path from day one kind
of got it so maybe it's not every kid
but me yeah I had a little rebellious
streak and maybe it was another way from
to leave a mark I wouldn't conform to
the way other kids acted I acted
differently listen to hardcore and
heavy-metal music and had a hardcore
attitude about things that attitude set
me apart from the pack once I was on the
outside of the normal kids I was
detached from them so I observed looking
in from the outside I garnered a better
understanding of the people I was
watching I saw their emotions their
cliques and their drama unfold from a
detached position I learned so so that's
an interesting point too that I fought
about while I was putting this together
I remember okay so you know you got the
kids movie reference Echo Charles
Breakfast Club yes sir so you got the
stereotypical kids right the jock yeah
the rebel guy you bend the preppy or the
popular girl yep the nervous will say
the nerd yeah and then what was the
black-haired girl considered like a
Rekluse like a hermit like outcasts
Artie Artie right give me artsy artsy
girl yeah yeah actually she was artsy
because remember she drew that picture
of the snow cabin and then she made her
- yeah you were correct okay so artsy
jock princess popular nerd and kind of
stereotypical rebel so at my school like
yeah we had all those kids right and I
really wasn't in any of those groups you
know saying so I kind of had I kind of
had friends in each one of those groups
which is kind of weird in its own right
I was friends with some of the popular
kids I was friends with some of the
burnouts I was friends with some of the
metalheads I was friends with some of
the prep like I was kind of friends had
a couple friends but I wasn't really
considered to be in any of those groups
which meant I was actually watching them
you know even from a young age I was
going oh yeah I see how the burnouts are
I see how their little hierarchy is you
know which is different but it allowed
me to kind of like look and learn
strange no man that makes perfect sense
you had a similar experience in high
school look first just real quick
that act of rebellion joined the
military is an act of rebellion oh yeah
it definitely was for a minute Kyle
carpenter is such a just a great dude
he's just a good guy but anybody that
does that is doing something that's
totally counter to what 99% of the
world's doing there's no question about
that yeah well yeah I mean his mom was
definitely against it we'll say and and
yet and but that's a cool thing about
Kyle
he's like he he talked them through it
you know he eventually was like good
enough to be like hey this is what I
really want to do and he remember he
went to he went to college to kind of
say okay I'll let me try college and
then you know he moved in that direction
I actually I joined the Navy I didn't
even tell my parents I just like joined
actually and I have I I noticed when I
wrote this I was like um reading a
little section I said like oh I was
talking to my dad and I had already
joined the Navy when I told my dad I was
I said yeah hey by the way I joined the
Navy and I think he was just kind of
stoked that I was not gonna go to jail
or just be an idiot for the rest of my
life
so yeah it's interesting how as I
reflect back just being on the outside
gave me maybe the initial idea of being
detached and looking at things from a
different perspective
only because I wasn't quite one of those
any of those groups interesting all
right
continuing on joining the Navy was still
the best thing I could've done it gave
me a blank slate and clear direction no
one in the Navy care that I didn't have
the best grades in high school it didn't
matter that I wasn't the best athlete no
one was concerned about where I was from
what my parents did or anything else
about my history they shaved my head
gave me a uniform and told me what I
needed to do to be successful
make your bed like this fold your
underwear like that polish your Boone
Dockers until they look like mirrors if
you could follow the rules and do what
you were told to do you would be put in
a leadership position I did follow the
rules and I did what I was told to do
and it paid off and I was made a squad
leader in boot camp what does that mean
tactically nothing
but it meant a lot to me at the time I
mean think about it a squad leader in
navy boot camp that that is a very
minimal leadership role but for me at
that time it was a role yes where there
are three squads I mean I think there's
more I think there was like six squads
because I we had a big open bay barracks
and I think there was three squads on
each side like but because you were
basically grouped by your bed your bunk
beds
yeah and so but yeah you needed a squad
leader so I probably had I don't know 15
people in my squad and there was another
guy who was from New England and he was
a wrestler and he was gonna be a seal
and he ended up beating see when he's an
awesome guy but he ended up being the
master-at-arms because he had been to
college and he you know his so he was
and then our our the guy that was the
recruit chief petty officer the RCP oh
so like the senior of all of the of the
recruits this guy was he had he had
turned down his commission or something
like that so he did ROTC for four years
the Navy paid for four years of college
and he said I don't want to get a
commission and they said cool you're
going to be an enlisted guy for two
years and that's what he did which when
she's really look I don't want to say
it's a bad call but that seems like a
bad call the video he got commissioned
yeah or he was ready to get his
Commission now who knows cuz everyone in
boot camp lies to each other when it
comes to like you know you meet all
these guys that were not just by her
there yeah I was just about to be you
know god I just got drafted by whatever
the the Miami Dolphins but I really
wanted to serve so I enlisted in the
Navy you're looking at that guy thinking
wow what position were you gonna play at
117 pounds but yeah so I'm not sure if
my RCP Oh was actually like maybe he got
in trouble right you go to four years of
college you're supposed to get your
commission and you get a DUI or
something oh hey you're not gonna
commission but you do owe us two years
of enlistment so he was there he was a
squared-away guy never know
remember what happened him but the
master-at-arms who was a total total
stud great guy awesome rest of wrestle
in college and he was the master-at-arms
and then I with no experience was a
squad leader
so my first my first leadership role and
I was stoked dude totally
that's something yeah yeah buds was the
same way for me I still wasn't great in
any particular skill not the best runner
or swimmer
not great at the obstacle course but I
could do what I was told I could play
the game and I wasn't going to quit some
people say that everyone thinks about
quitting during buds I never did not for
a second but that thought never crossed
my mind hell week a five day block of
continuous physical training with almost
no sleep whatsoever and which causes the
highest number of people to quit was
actually relaxing for me because during
hell week
nothing is timed during all of the
facets of buds students are constantly
on the clock timed runs swims an
obstacle course evolutions take place
every day if you missed the time and
fail one of them you are on the bubble
and if you fail again you're out that's
what it was when I went through it was
stressful but during hell week
nothing was timed you just had to keep
going you just had to not quit and for
me that was the easy part
pretty straightforward that's a good
skill to have it's like the other thing
genetically I don't have to sleep a lot
and that is that that was I picked the
perfect career for that like I'm saying
it wasn't good at anything which is true
not the best runner middle the pack
runner middle the pack swimmer middle
the pack on the obstacle course but and
and I didn't really think about the not
sleeping thing but that is something
that I had and I didn't really realize
it at that time but when I got done with
hell week
I remember my roommates were beat up you
know and tired and I remember I remember
I slept fur you know like I solid eight
hours or something and I got up and I
was doing eight count bodybuilders now
rock'n'roll what they were like good
yeah so good times ha when I got them
with buzz I checked into SEAL team one
was fired up as all of us were who were
checking into that sacred place of war
heroes and legends the Master Chief of
the command the highest ranking enlisted
seal at team one welcomed us aboard no
one here cares that you made it through
buds we all did it doesn't mean anything
here you have to prove yourselves and
earn your Trident so keep your mouth
shut your ears open and don't forget
anything and be on time any questions
the Trident was the gold insignia worn
on the uniform which indicates you're a
seal to receive our Trident we had to go
through a six-month probationary period
and then go through a written and oral
review board with the senior enlisted
personnel at the team we were all
nervous about that and the Master Chief
provided no comfort whatsoever in the
early 90s and again I'm skipping through
chunks of the book just to kind of get
to the meat in the early 90s when I got
to SEAL team 1 the training progression
was different from how it is now back
then once onboard a team you were
eventually assigned to a seal platoon
this is where you would actually learn
to be a seal up until that point the
training wasn't tactical and buds you
don't learn very much about the actual
job of being a seal you learn how to be
called wet and tired and miserable and
not to complain about any of it
but you don't learn any of the job
skills that make you into a professional
operator those skills were taught to you
once you were in a seal platoon there
you learned through a fire hose there
was so much knowledge needed so many
skills to develop so many tactics to
understand you felt as if you would
never know it all but like the rest of
the new guys I listened and learned
every single day in my first three
platoons I learned a few key concepts
that stuck with me for the rest of my
career and they were also the base upon
which I built most of the principles I
ended up teaching to the rest of the
SEAL Teams and eventually to companies
businesses and organizations around the
globe these are examples of the lucky
moments I referred to earlier I was in
the right place at the right time with
the right frame of mind to learn what I
did then I was lucky enough to have it
other experiences to overlay what I had
learned and slowly subconsciously begin
to formulate a system of leadership
that I was then lucky enough to apply on
one of the most challenging battlefields
in the world the Battle of Ahmadi in the
summer of 2006 when I returned from that
deployment I took over the training for
the West Coast SEAL Teams
were I formalized codified and
transcribed what I had learned but the
roots of everything I eventually wrote
down originated in a very
non-traditional but highly effective
learning environment the seal platoon
yeah so that's the opening kind of a
little a little uh an excerpts of the
opening of the book just to kind of if
people have no idea who I am
hey this is who I am yeah the biggest
takeaway from that because most of the
people listening just like me aren't
seals and are gonna be seals the thing
that you said that I think is the most
important of all that is the thing about
frame of mind because what happens in
the circumstances at all you can't
control any of those things but
everybody is going to be exposed to some
things in their life and if you have the
right frame of mind you can you can
actually learn from it you were talking
about being in high school it isn't just
that you had different groups of friends
if you're like me which I think you were
even in high school you're looking and
saying I can see the glide path for that
group it's not guaranteed but if they
keep down this road I could tell in high
school where these different groups were
likely gonna go some appealed to me some
did not appeal to me and even in high
school if you have the right frame of
mind you can actually start to learn the
the biggest problem with that is I was
an idiot in high school and I didn't
have the right frame of mind you can't
control those those lessons but if you
actually have just enough a tiny bit of
willingness to just kind of pay
attention to what's going on around you
you have to be in the SEAL Teams to get
these same lessons they're all out there
in life everywhere and that would be
people always ask me if he could go back
and do it all over again what would you
change and I'm like I usually say
nothing I actually would try to tell
young Dave Burke hit your frame of mind
just paying just pay a little more
attention what's going on around you
because it's all out there even in high
school it's all there man you know the I
got asked this the other day I was
getting interviewed or something and and
I've been asked it before and it's a
similar kind of concept right the
question was
what was the moment where this all kinda
came together and I kind of wanted to
give a dramatic you know a dramatic
answer a poignant answer oh I remember
it was a it was a rainy day and it was
like you know the every one of these
things is a slow build and like you
don't even know you don't have the front
right frame of mind right you don't have
the right frame of mind to say oh this
is what this is what's happening right
now but you can look back that's what
I'm doing now is even you know writing
that forward looking back in my life
saying wait how did I where did I come
to these conclusions because at some
point I definitely did at some point I
recognized these things but it was a
slow I shouldn't say that at some point
over time I got to a point I arrived at
a point now that is true when when I
that you've heard me tell the story of
taking over the training for the West
Coast SEAL Teams and I went out on that
training operation was a total disaster
and I went back to my barracks room that
night and wrote down the four laws of
combat that's that's it right there like
that was what happened but when I wrote
down the four laws of combat for the
first time I wasn't trying to figure
them out I wasn't trying to see what
they were I knew what they were and I
just had to write them down I had
learned him over and over again from a
bunch of different people and in a bunch
of different ways and so now it was okay
cool how can I explain these to the rest
of these guys that are gonna be coming
through this training where they can
take them in and implement them quickly
yeah so it there's unfortunately there's
no point now my curiosity is when
someone gets fed this information now
right when someone that's at the basic
school in the Marine Corps yeah listens
to the podcast that we did that series
of podcasts and goes is that do they get
just a a hyper move forward because I
look at it and think man if I would have
had this podcast
when I was younger I'd been a million
times in a better position is that do
people get a hyper boost do you think
I bet you some people do but I still
think that you're fighting against some
of the human nature that I'm not even
convinced that Dave Burke in a time
machine would still have the maturity
even being told exactly how this could
work in your favor to have the frame of
mind to listen to it there's a but there
are undoubtedly some folks I guarantee
you that are seeing this and go holy
crap
without this my life would be different
and theirs so a whole bunch of people
that you can hit over the head and then
they're not gonna absorb it and that
they have their own timelines but you
can see when people get dialed in and in
the military I mean those culminating
events like you're just talking about
you get a couple of them in your career
you get maybe two or three if you're
lucky some people get one a lot of
people don't get any I'm in touch with a
pretty good number of guys going through
the base of school and social media and
whatnot and they are so much more dialed
in than I ever was so much more dialed
in and I think you know that's a
combination of things I started in the
piece I'm Marine Corps and I think it's
a different viewpoint and they started
in war foot wartime Marine Corps but
those kids seem to be way more dialed in
and they're absorbing this and paying
attention to this you know even Jay I
was Jason Gardner at some point was
saying I think it was one who was on the
podcast he was saying like hey he
started at Justin he's a master chief
yeah then he was adjusting his gait he's
listened to the podcast he's like Yelp
but here's like here's what's going on
he's like he and so his mind was open
enough you don't reminds me of my I was
uh I don't know what age I was but I
wanted to get a new bike and I was at
that age where you know I grew up in a
small town and if you were gonna ride
somewhere it was a you know it was it
was work right it wasn't it wasn't it
was more than a three minute bike ride
you know and I think I had saved up
whatever 70 bucks or something and I
asked my dad hey I really need a new
bike can you can you know can we split
the cost or whatever and he says okay
you know so cool cuz what does that mean
for him means it doesn't have to worry
about driving around I mean it's
basically yeah I'll leave him alone
so I go and you know we go to the bike
store and I go to get the bike and I and
I'm gonna get a BMX bike and I'm at that
age where I could get a ten-speed so
that it was that point like I'd never
even had speeds before but all of a
sudden I'm old enough so I was probably
12 or something where I could get a 10
speed you know with the curve down
handlebars yeah and my dad's they can
yeah you know you got a bike three four
six miles five miles whatever you're
gonna want this 10 speed yeah and of
course I'm like no I want this BMX bike
so we ended he ends up I mean he said
you can see they were looking back at
the conversation he's just looking at me
saying thinking to himself you're an
idiot you're gonna want this bike and I
said no I definitely want this BMX bikes
I'm gonna go off-road or whatever and
sure enough we get to we get to BMX bike
and you know two days later after my
fourth you know six mile bike ride into
town I'm thinking I wanted that dead
speed so there's certain this is the
problem with life the problem with life
is that there's certain lessons that
only life can teach you now what I hope
is like when you give me that feedback
about the basic school like what I hope
is you go okay yeah I there's there's
some lieutenant's going through and and
I get the same thing guys in the teams
right now the young jail is and the
teams I get are me I mean we have all
kinds of army guys maybe even in
Australia that was cool a bunch of army
a bunch of army guys that were coming up
saying hey this is what I'm doing -
thank you yep learn this learn that so I
think you can make more rapid progress
if you have the right frame of mind
going in without a doubt and there's
more out there now than there was to be
able to figure that out sooner and there
are guys and gals out there certainly in
the military doing it way sooner than I
did it has some Oh in the SEAL Teams
when you get done with a job like you
get done with being an assistant platoon
commander and now you're ready to be
good at it you're not allowed to do it
anymore
it's over total by the time you have it
figured out you're done with it yep the
platoon commander
all right I think I've got this dialed
now it's over and it's time to become
Latasha commander by the time you feel
good about being at asking the commander
okay you know I'm sorry
and I was super lucky again see they
talk about luck a lot so I was a prior
enlisted guy when I was an assistant
platoon commander the only person in my
platoon at SEAL team two that had more
experience than me was the platoon chief
who is another guy from Team one that we
kind of grew up together in the teams he
was he was a little bit more he'd been
in the teams a little bit longer than me
but not too much longer so we were like
the experienced guys when I was a
platoon commander same thing like I was
my platoon chief had been in for
probably an extra six months longer than
me but after that it was just a bunch of
you know basically guys that have been
for six years we'd been in for 13 or 14
don't any when I was at asking the
commander it was like Tony Tony or fradi
you know and he had been in for probably
two or three years longer than me but
then after that it was just people that
had been in for you know less than half
the time and half the amount of
experience so that's luck you know so
when I'm doing a task in the commander
now I'm talking about how I was
developing my skills even as the tasking
commander I had been in for 15 years
imagine a normal task unit commander
that's only been in for six years or or
nagas they've been in for seven years or
eight years that's a normal tasking
writer I've been in for 15 I had taught
I'd been an instructor at SEAL team one
in the training Department I'd done land
warfare trip after land warfare trip I'd
done CQB trip after CQB trip I've talked
I taught everything and that was when I
was when I was a young single guy - I
was in the Training Command - guess what
guess what trips I went on all of them
all of them told like oh you need
someone to go out to the desert cool I'm
I'm in you need someone to go to this
new mount facility and we've never taken
with you in okay I'm going no factor so
that's why I was so lucky because and
this is another thing when you're an
instructor when you're an instructor
you're de facto detached so now I'm
watching these jao's go through and I'm
like oh yes guys making all kinds of
mistakes here's what because he's all
caught up and it wears I can see
everything because I'm watching him and
I can connect the dots
Oh
when you can see everything matter fact
I was talking to Andrew Paul about this
Andrew Paul was going through something
as a reserve he's a reservist to the
teams and he was going through some
training but he was observing and he's I
could see everything oh yeah man yes yes
that's it that's that's the mindset you
have to have so that's why you know I I
like to emphasize the fact that I was
very lucky the even the the frame of
mind that I had wasn't because I was
advanced beyond the other people it was
it was I got lucky that I had had a
little bit more I wasn't more senior but
I had more time I had more experience
and those experiences early on opened up
and put me in the right frame of mind
luckily so what I do then in this in
this book I go through these first three
Co patents which are very there's this
kind of does this happen I guess it
happens in everything when you learn
something for the first time but this
happens in the teams all the time the
way people learn something for the first
time is the way they think is correct
forever for sure and it takes like a
beat down to get it out of them dude
unlearning that yeah it's this I think
it's probably same everywhere but
certainly in in aviation - when you
learn it from somebody else because
first of all the guy teaching you you
think is a God because he's teaching you
you don't know anything about him other
than he's the teacher so he must be
better than everybody at this and when
you learn it and you figured out that is
the answer forever I had a guy I had two
guys that were like Vietnam era and one
of them was saying to do something some
away and I knew it was wrong which is
crazy to think about right but what
happened was we were doing while I'd
done two back-to-back our deployments
which is out on a ship with the Marine
Corps with the Navy we're doing over the
beach all the time every operation we
did was was from the ship to the ribs
boats from the ribs to zodiacs from the
zodiacs across the beach I mean I did
over and over look I'd done
I did so many over the beach ops we and
it's over the beach officer so did you
ever do over the beach ops there's
they're so ridiculously they're so
ridiculously hard I mean everything like
you're gonna swim in so everything is
going to be wet all your radios are
gonna be and this is before we had
waterproof radio so everything had to be
waterproof properly your weapons are
gonna get trashed
I mean it's you're gonna be freezing
it's gonna be there's waves it's it
makes everything I want to give an
accurate assessment I would say that if
you compare to like hey we're gonna take
a helicopter to this target and we're
gonna land it we're not patrol in
compared to we're gonna take boats I
want to go over the beach and swim in I
think it's probably I would say six
times harder this it's six times harder
because of weight maybe maybe maybe four
maybe four to six times harder it's that
much harder I'm thinking about the
preparation that you'd have to do and
the worries that you haven't had where
you'd have a problem like you're let's
face it once you're on the ground you're
not gonna have a problem yeah like we
got this you're you're bringing the
boats in at night you're sending swimmer
scouts in to go there and signal but the
beach I mean you're losing people bro
it's crazy and then you're swimming in
there's waves your boats can get turned
over your motors can fail there's just
total it's it makes everything so much
harder so I had this Vietnam guy Vietnam
era guy that was saying to do something
a certain way and I'm not gonna get into
the taxi but he was saying to do a thing
a certain way and I knew that it was
wrong because I had just got done with
to our tunes where I did mission
information after mission and I knew
that that was not the right thing to do
and the other Vietnam guy said hey man
he's wrong he's wrong just play the game
a little bit and in the actual thing
that he told me was people don't always
remember things right he was just being
merciful about he wasn't being a jerk
here just like look people don't always
remember things right so those but but
the way you
learn something in your first person so
this guy probably learned the guy that
was telling us to do something a certain
way probably learn this from somebody
somewhere along the route along the way
and just thought it was the right way to
do things and I had learned through
actual experience like hey you do this
enough times go over the beach and go to
Red Beach Camp Pendleton in the middle
of the winter when there's a 8-foot
swell and you're getting cleaned out if
you learn and you learn what to do and
you get good at it and I think that Pete
the way people learn things for the
first time is it leaves a mark on people
and it's very hard to change their minds
so you got to be careful with that
there's probably so is there a bias
around that echo Charles like an
official bias like the way you learn
something for the first time are you
always biased towards thinking that's
correct
mmm is that an official type of bias not
that I can think okay good but it's very
possible yes okay so we have a possible
bias possible by did I think that's
really hard to undo really hard oh yeah
I saw that all throughout my career in a
whole bunch not just in flying a whole
bunch of different things people wrap
their heads around that and it's really
hard on do that yeah I saw that all the
time and and I saw it in myself and as
soon as I saw it myself
I recognized okay your this is just what
you learned and what you learned can be
wrong yeah I mean that's the frame of
mind we were talking about but before
you you and I we talk about all the time
is the phrase of question everything and
it's that question everything to be a
jerk about things it's it's actually
question yourself more than anything is
do I not actually understand this the
way I think I do does that guy know
something or have seen something or
experience something that maybe I
haven't and the questioning is what it
is is actually questioning yourself more
than anything is is what I know actually
correct and that's I think that's part
of the reason why it's so hard to undo
that is it people are convinced they
understand it and it's really hard to
undo that the questioning is yourself of
is this right and a lot of people aren't
don't have the frame of mind to do that
yeah it's a trap it is a trap it's a
trap you got to be careful of it so
getting back to the book here I in this
part section one found
stations this is I go through kind of
these first fundamental three platoons
where I learned and the reason I went on
this whole tangent about learning things
for the first time is because this is
what I saw these certain principles for
the first time and again it wasn't like
I saw the principles like oh there it is
I got this it was like this is where the
seed got planted and it started to grow
the first Platoon the first section here
is called detach it was in my first
platoon that I learned the power of
being able to detach myself from the
chaos and mayhem going on take a step
back and see what was actually happening
I was lucky that it happened the way
that it did
so I go through the entire I go through
the entire evolution of me learning that
and that is one of those moments where I
absolutely remember it happening so when
though if the guy would have asked me
hey when did you learn to detach instead
of asking me broadly what when did all
this stuff come together I couldn't
answer that but when I learned to detach
absolutely to remember it on an oil rig
doing training no one's making a call I
end up making a call my second platoon
when I learned in my second platoon
second platoon had him had a mutiny
and I saw the difference between
arrogance and I saw humility and I saw I
saw the stark difference into what
following someone that's arrogant was
like and following someone that is
humble is like and I ended up with I
started with the most arrogant platoon
leader and we had a mutiny and we
rebelled against him and he got fired
and then we ended up with the most
humble and knowledgeable and squared
away
platoon commander and the attitude that
we had with the arrogant guy we would I
don't think we sabotage on a regular
basis but there was like sub-continent a
training mission that he had forced his
plan down our throat we didn't want that
thing to succeed we wanted to prove him
wrong and I don't know if that was
always a conscious thing I think most
it was subconscious but no doubt we
didn't want to follow him and think
about think about how disturbing that is
you're in a seal platoon and the platoon
commander there's not one single guy in
the entire platoon that actually wants
to follow that guy yeah and this is the
frame of mind thing I I had to trace
this back I didn't say why I didn't say
we don't like him because he's arrogant
I didn't I couldn't I wasn't smart
enough to figure that out I just knew
that we didn't like that guy we don't
like that guy and what made it so clear
was when the next guy came in to take
his place nice and he's super humble and
even then it didn't strike me it wasn't
until I actually thought about it from a
leadership perspective why did we hate
that guy and wind waterfall we know one
in a seal platoon wants to follow their
leader that's disgusting
yeah and then you get another guy same
group same seal platoon exact same guys
and you get a humble guy that gives
ownership and all of a sudden we will do
anything for this guy and to make sure
that we don't let this guy down yeah but
when people get people gonna get the
book when they read it there's more in
there when they and I won't give it too
much away but you talk in more details
there's other things about the lessons
that in looking back on you can call
those luck too but you were actually
lucky that your boss in that very first
story didn't crush you and just destroy
and wipe out the opportunity to tell her
in that lesson when you made that call
because some bosses could have just worn
you down and put you in a position never
do it again
you're actually lucky that on that
second platoon that that mutinies story
actually lucky in some ways that they
let you know that hey we don't do this
oh there's others there's all these
other layers of things in there isn't
just that hey we had a bad boss and then
we had a good boss it's actually that
you could you that you had the frame of
mind I would keep saying that over and
over again to look back and you didn't
get validated like oh yeah well you have
a problem just come to me and I'll take
care of it and these problems go away
yeah it was like no you go back to work
and so there's other pieces in there too
I gotta cut you off because the
you go back to the first example this is
why luck is important the first example
is we're on this oil rig and no one's
making a decision I take a step back and
I make a call and to your point I didn't
get crushed I didn't get told to shut up
I didn't get called told hey new guy you
need to you need to you know shut up and
do what you're told to do that the fact
that no one did that to me made me say
oh okay this is a good thing so so what
that is luck cuz believe me you have a
seal platoon of 16 guys the chances that
there's a brow beater I didn't even know
what the word brow beater was that is an
actual type of human being right I'm
surprised there wasn't one in The
Breakfast Club
I'll brow beat her you know what I mean
actually I guess there was what about
the principal what was his name
Michael Charles this is your moment of
truth right here Becker Decker
Jonna playing yeah I wasn't ready
yeah buddy what's a brow bleeders Oh or
is this someone when you give your idea
and you just they just come at you I
mean they're just thrown off and they're
basically they're just they're just
punching you in the face with you know
you come and say hey do you think it'd
be good to start releasing the podcast
on Tuesdays that's actually that's one
of the dumbest ideas I've ever heard
yeah so you know what actually you
having fun if you thought through that
you haven't thought through that because
if you were to fall through that you'd
realize that Wednesday is the day when
people are waiting for the pockets we
put out on Tuesday you know what
actually don't come to me with any more
ideas that don't make any sense
whatsoever validate them through common
sense before you approach me because
it's actually a waste of my time it's a
waste of your time it makes you look
stupid
that's what a bra bra they just bring it
they don't let you do that what yeah it
was kind of built up over ha ha
understand so you you do have a brow
beater if I would had a brow beater in
that first Platoon and actually there
was a couple guys that were borderline
browbeat her sir and first for whatever
reason Prabhas it was the right thing at
the right moment they decided not to
beat me down
so what is that luck yeah that is luck
now
the second story in again as you
mentioned like the details of these
stories I put a lot of details so people
could really hear what I
yeah that mutiny we had the the arrogant
platoon commanders out of line takes a
swing at one of the enlisted guys tries
to hit one of these little guys we break
them up and again I explained this in
the book people getting in a fight in
the seal platoon is no this is not this
is not a big deal this is this is a
violent group of dudes that are on all
kinds of they got all kinds of
testosterone running through their blood
like this is it this is a gang you know
and okay so it's not that big a deal but
when it's the platoon commander that no
one likes and that no one respects and
that is totally arrogant all of a sudden
we turned on him like boom now we had
something
but even then to your point Dave the
commanding officer wasn't like okay guys
thank you for the input I'll get rid of
him he goes you guys this sounds like a
mutiny we don't have him you knees in
the SEAL Teams or in the Navy get out of
here go do your jobs it's like okay like
what that was not a good this is not
normal and then luckily that commanding
officer was smart enough to actually dig
into it further and he relieved the guy
got fired he fired him so yeah and that
is luck it's luck that the commanding
officer number one told us shut up do
your job and number two he was smart
enough to say you know what I'm gonna
get rid of this guy no those are lucky
circumstances so that contrasts another
thing that was lucky
if I would have had the horrible platoon
commander and then okay one I may not
have noticed if I would have had an okay
platoon commander and then a phenomenal
one I may not have noticed I went from
one end of the spectrum from from the
worst platoon commander and that I could
imagine to the best platoon commander
that I could imagine and it's just like
anything else right you don't we need to
what as human beings there needs to be
some discrepancy for us to notice it
right we need city contrast yes some
contrast there was a big enough contrast
that even my dumb ass at whatever 22 or
23 years old
when
oh I see you what's going on I see
what's going on and that second book
that second platoon commander the good
one that's actually the seed that
started in my mind of oh he's an officer
he was enlisted like me I'm enlisted
like he was maybe I could become an
officer just like this way because I
wouldn't have even imagined that it
wasn't even something that I fought I
wasn't like hey you know I need to
become an officer that never even
crossed my mind because we were you know
the enlisted the the e5 mafia at SEAL
team one we didn't want to be officers
we didn't like officers you know it was
that whole attitude there's so much
detail though that those details are
really important and the takeaways those
you had you still have to be looking for
that stuff and and you can now if you
can look for that that contrast is
actually out there and I know you can't
cover everything in the podcast but
those details even in the book the way
you wrote it each one of those details
is something to pay attention to those
little things so when you read this I
mean you have to read every line every
every piece of that because there's a
there's a take away from each one of
those the contrast is there if you if
you know to look for it and the biggest
problem certainly for me and sure is you
just don't know to look for it and and
luckily those things happen with enough
contrast for you to recognize her even
look back on it you gotta you gotta know
to look for it yeah and I think well
what we do now we don't need to see you
know we can see little little gray area
we can go yeah yeah well here's what's
going on here we don't need to see
someone that's a total error again the
person that's only my way of highway we
don't need to see all that we can see
someone that's leaning in that direction
and say hey you know why you're getting
this pushback here here's why it's just
a little pushback because you're doing
this and we get to see that easier
because we're looking for it yeah but
whether I would have seen this out of
the gate without that broad contrast
probably not too dumb so then we get to
the third Platoon platoon and this is
where again I go into a lot of details
on the story what actually happened that
you could pick apart you can say oh yeah
that's what that was but fundamentally I
did the same thing I did in that first
thing where I made a call
made a decision I was detached I was
doing the right thing I saw what's
called make and I made a call and once I
made the call but the tune commander was
like mm hey why did you do that and I
said well good and I reviewed in my mind
the cocky arrogant the ego my ego was
the immediate voice that popped up
you know the terminators you know in the
Terminator echo yes when you when he's
gonna say something
he gets an option of multiple responses
that flash up in his led heads-up
display Judi yeah what is it yeah this
heads-up displays HUD so I get that
mm-hmm when this guy says why did you
make that call
I get though well cuz you're too slow to
make a call or you should have been
quick or you didn't see what was
happening or cause I'm detached and I
see all those little arrogant responses
pops up in it and thankfully thankfully
I just jerked the collar on that just
the chain and said well you're an
arrogant right now probably a little bit
of that arrogant platoon commander that
I had I felt that little yeah I felt
that little I felt his spirit in my
brain I smashed it with the good with
the humility and I I did respond saying
well you know I I wasn't sure I didn't
hear you make it a call so you know I
just I made one and then he said well I
didn't want to I didn't want to retreat
from the target I wanted assessing and
and then I realized that number one
being a leader doesn't mean that you
have to be making the call every single
time it doesn't mean that at all in fact
being a good leader means when you're
supporting what the leader the real
leader the overall leader is want to do
what's good for TPO that's what you're
supposed to do
and it was a good ego check for me it's
not all about me and so let's always
take a step back and make sure you know
it's cool to be attached and see what to
do tactically how about Jocko detach and
see what's best for the team and see how
you can support your leader
and see how you can be a team player so
that was the you know the next important
sort of lesson that I learned that stuck
with me cuz how many times throughout
the rest of my career was it hey it's
this guy's idea or that guy oh it's my
idea or the other guy's idea how many
times did I did that play out you wanna
I cannot count the number of times the
your idea versus my idea that happened
an infinite number of times yeah your
idea versus my idea and learning that
lesson of you know what what's what's
what's the best idea and what are we
really trying to get done and is the
boss whoever that boss is cuz man it's
so easy especially when you're young and
you're young you want to do well you
want to perform you you want to be the
guy right it's so easy that when the
opportunity comes for you to be the guy
to just jump up and beat your chest and
be the guy and it feels good that that
short-term gratification of like putting
your chest out like yeah I made that
call and it's such a short-term gain and
long-term strategic loss to do that and
that's what I learned when the time I
made the call and I actually should have
actually should have kept the mouth shut
alright so those are the first the first
little sections about that and then I
get into the laws of combat and the
principles of leadership and pretty
pretty straightforward like a review you
know cover moves simple prioritize and
execute details coming I'll tell you
what though
as I'm writing that down it's
interesting because now yeah you know
we've traveled the world we've taught
these principles over and over again to
people and teams and organizations of
every imaginable kind and it's these
things apply
the biggest question I get when I'm when
we're working is how do you apply they
understand what they mean and you can
say those words and they can define them
and explain them and the question people
always have is how do I apply this and
those those three stories of those three
platoons and then when you kind of
basically you review extreme ownership
and dichotomy you know briefly but you
kind of just go through the review and
where they came from is really what sets
the stage for how these where these fit
and how to look for work for where they
fit I mean even that story about the
platoon commander of whether or not you
should have made the call I mean there's
there's the seeds of balance in there to
is hey the same situation in previous
platoon actually that platoon commander
did the exact same thing but for a
totally different reason oh my people
are all different and the way I treat
this one guy and relate to this one guy
doesn't work in every situation and when
you talk about that too is when you look
at other people's plans because ego is
always the biggest issue with every
client we work with it's always ego is
at the top and the question that you ask
how important is this plan to that other
person because if the another person has
to do this plan the worst thing you can
do is fight them on the planet no matter
whatever the quality of the plan is and
even having the humility of saying hey
in this situation it isn't even about
what is the best plan it's what's the
best way to implement the plan because
if I prove that I'm right and my plan is
better and this guy has to admit to me
an echo has to be okay your plan is
better what are the likelihood that
guy's gonna be totally on board with
supporting my it's not gonna happen what
is the likely that that person's looking
for you to fall on your face don't
likelihood they help you forward that
they even even by kind of like you sit
on a second platoon maybe not sabotage
but by just doing nothing when you
actually what you need them is to do the
exact opposite of that which is totally
be in the game so even as you read those
reviews those first three to set the
stage and even though it review of a oh
and dichotomy I don't care how many
times you've read those books read it in
this context because it changes in your
mind how they apply to the world that
that you care about which is your world
which doesn't have to be the SEAL Teams
it's not what this is about
just that just the backdrop it's
actually where it where it fits and
whatever world that you're in not meant
in the future by the way like you know
how if you have a better plan they have
a good plan you have a batter you have
at level 10 this guy is a level 9 and
you he's like no no this plan it's good
it's clean it's good and you're like
none other than mind so much better than
yours and bones force them to do it
right yeah and not only during that plan
they might not do their best but in the
future you're like the guy who's I call
you just think your plan is better so
even in the future he might not have
your back is much why would you even why
are you even gonna put forth that effort
echo if when you brought me a plan that
was a level 9 yeah good plan a good plan
and I was like no mine's a level 10
we're not using your plan how much
effort are you gonna put in next time to
come up with a good plan yeah I mean
that's we'll just say let potentially
less I'll tell ya and I mean you want to
talk about this is real-world
application I mean this is you and I
work together you know you come up with
plans for things sometimes yeah yeah and
and unless the plan is egregious I'm
sitting back over here going okay that's
the way you want to set the stuff up
cool okay sounds good you wanna do you
want to show up at 9:59 for a 10 o'clock
for a 10 o'clock you know scenario but
even with that if it's you and me I go
hey 10 o'clock you know 9:59 all good if
if it's you mean and let's say we're
having a guest on and I'll be hey man
guest and I know you know what that
means that means like hey that means
you're not letting me down it means
we're looking bad you don't look bad you
know so all good yeah but I'm not I'm
not I'm not saying hey there's a guest
you better be here by 9:30 all set up I
just tell you what's up and you know
what to do if it's true communication
yes understanding understanding the
intent yeah Dave Burke maybe doesn't
fully qualify as a as a full guest
anymore yeah you're mine he's like a
hybrid like a guest friend he was not
quite enough to get here at 9:30 but a
solid 950
yeah well this space said I was here
tonight 959 but
you do the point remains the offense
under Jack Jack I mean this is you know
and same with like a national on front
we're doing all kinds of things in
national on front all kinds of things I
actually talked about this in the muster
in Australia really the most I've talked
really I mean not a ton but several
times I used in his example that at you
know the actual national on front muster
there's a lot of moving parts there's a
lot of things happening there's there's
video audio visual stuff happening
there's kids being made to hand out to
people there's PT going on there's so
much this there's registration happening
there's check-in there's hand out of
stuff there's organizing the table
there's all this there's there's just
there's just huge logistical things that
are happening how much do I know of
what's going on next to none next to
none and Jamie who runs the muster like
she knows she knows what the intent is
and if she feels like there's a little
oh I'm not calling 900 percent on this
one I'm not sure she'll be like hey
Jocko should we do this or this and I'll
be like well what do you think and she
says well I think it to be smooth us
like that's cool
makes sense but as far as me actually
directing anything it's very very seldom
am i saying no we need to do this way
occasionally we will occasionally we
will occasionally I will occasionally
I'll say yeah no that's not a good plan
and we're not gonna do it that way and
when and as you see when I say that
people go yeah very seldom does someone
want to get in a debate with me about
something that I'm firm on I'm firm so
sofa because you hardly ever do it yeah
yeah I'm firm so seldom that when I am
people don't there's something we're not
seeing here so so yeah it's it's the
going back to this the just review of
extreme ownership the review that
economy leadership important because
just like when you read the manual about
machine gunning cool it talks
the purpose of the machine gun right and
that's why I specifically read those two
sections from the Marine Corps one of
them and this is the purpose of the
machine gun this is the principle of
what a machine gun does the next one is
how you actually do that as how it
applies this is how you shoot that
weapon from a bipod here's where you put
the the shoulder here's where you put
the weapon on your shoulder you probably
sure that's what I'm talking about here
so we got the principles and I have to
cover them here but then how do we get
into you know actually putting that
shooting that weapon from the bipod how
do we actually fire these principles how
do we execute them alright next section
and again I know we didn't coordinate
about which sections to talk about and
there's a ton of sections I just try to
I just kind of was going through gonna
eye this one this one will be good but
skipping here this one is called the
power of relationships the power of
relationships and this is one of those
things one of those things you hear all
the time right relationships are
important let me tell you how important
they are 99.9% of the things that I did
in my entire military career were based
on relationships and not based on chain
of command 99.9 percent I'm not even
tremendous I'm sure it's in there
somewhere but 99.9% of the things that I
did in my military career were based on
relationships so that goes when I'm
talking about being that commander of
task unit bruiser and we have an
operation and lathe is going to be the
the assault force commander or the
Ground Force commander on an operation
I'm not saying hey life here's how
you're gonna do it I'm saying hey life
here's what we got what do you think and
we together have a relationship we
formulate a plan or he forms that
formulates a plan and comes to me and
says hey this is what I want to do and I
that looks good right down to when my
boss would say hey Jocko here's what I
want you to do I'd say okay boss let me
interpret that does this make sense is
this what you really want is this does
this is this can I turn this on this
direction and
a little bit more in the opposite way so
I can get achieve this result instead
all that is based on relationships so
developing these relationships is is the
most important than 99.9% of what you do
should be from the relationships you
have going back to the book there is
another key element to leading any
exceptional team relationships leaders
leadership requires relationships good
relationships with people above you
below you and beside you in the chain of
command are critical for a strong team
the better the relationships the more
open and effective communication there
is the more communication there is the
stronger the team will be for example
there are times when a boss is driving
forward on a less than ideal path that
needs to be redirected if you have a
good relationship with the boss you can
explain tactfully what you see to be
errors in their thoughts and ideas as
always the approach you use to discuss
this is important put the onus on
yourself as to why the idea doesn't make
sense for example you know boss I really
want to support the plan to the best of
my ability but I'm having a hard time
understanding how to execute this part
of it can you explain why you want it
done that way so I can get it right so
that right there is how you shoot the
weapon from a bipod right that is it now
the conversation is open and you can
begin to figure out why the boss's idea
is what it is and what you can do to
influence that idea but before even
getting to that point ask yourself some
simple questions first how much will be
gained by approaching the Boston trying
to convince them to change their plan if
the difference is minimal it's probably
not worth investing any time or effort
into it next ask yourself how much of
your concern is just your ego there is a
chance that you see it your way of doing
things
there is a chance that you see your way
of doing something as smarter or more
efficient than what the boss has offered
if that is the case and you don't truly
think there is much to be gained by
using your method let it go
don't create drama over Yuriko lastly
ask yourself if you will be moving your
relationship with your boss forward or
backward by raising this issue and I've
been hammering that like at the muster
at the muster I've been saying hey every
conversation I'm gonna have with another
person is to improve the relationship
that's like priority number one
prioritize next to you priority number
one I'm gonna improve our relationship
if I'm gonna have a conversation with
Dave our relationship is getting better
Dave's walking around walking away from
the conversation going man I hope I can
do good by Chaco as opposed to walking
away shaking his head going I hope that
guy forgot to take out his garbage
Monday morning he has to wait another
week you know like just small curses you
can put on me right you've had that
happen Echo Charles yes sir I have
that's all ya know kind of annoying very
annoying it's not like it's not like a
life-threatening thing you don't like it
and it's so Dave walks away from the
conversation he doesn't want to he
doesn't want to kill me but he doesn't
want me to have clean garbage cans
either so when I have a conversation I'm
looking to improve the situations do we
we talk about leadership capital Flynn
and I work Flynn Cochran and I are
working together all the time
we're at the point now that we talk
about that concept of leadership capital
not in sort of the theoretical ins we at
the beginning of our training when we
start to work with companies and we're
gonna do four years the very first thing
we start with after setting the table of
all these concepts is leadership capital
and the question you ask yourself every
single time is what I'm going to do a
deposit or is it a withdrawal and when
people think in those terms they this
book is called leadership strategy and
tactics are you thinking strategically
in this even in this conversation that
we're having and you know the idea but
what is the likelihood this is going to
advance my relationship the answer is
99.9% of the time gonna be super obvious
it's gonna stare you in the face and if
you think strategically you will almost
never make a leadership withdrawal
you'll almost never have any capital
you're taken out of the bank and then
when you you said don't don't create
drama over your ego and when your ego
gets in the way almost every single time
even when you get what you want you are
taking it you're taking money out of the
gallery you're depleting your leadership
capital until eventually you have none
and nobody wants you to win
um it's amazing that it's so obvious
like this is so obvious
yeah and yet people make people
absolutely make that mistake time and
time again the other thing about this
that's interesting or if you want to
take a like another perspective of it is
if my goal indigo in going into a
conversation is to improve my
relationship with you does that make me
some kind of some kind of a fake person
right oh I'm a fake person because I'm
just trying to trick Dave into liking me
it's like no actually I want us to win
yeah and by the way I you know this goes
back to the difference between
leadership and manipulation which I
talked about so if if my goal is to get
you to do something that's gonna benefit
me
yeah that's manipulation and it's wrong
if my goal in getting improving our
relationship is so that our team can do
better we can accomplish our mission and
both those things by the way benefit you
well guess what that's called
it's called leadership so you know with
that oh you know house because some
people on the flip side of that whole
spectrum is like they'll do that but
it's almost like and I guess it's a
question freeze so you know like okay
your voice coming to America remember
that that show Eddie Murphy
so it was is where Eddie Murphy's
African guy and they're like princes or
something yeah yeah yeah yeah he created
Arsenio Hall was also in that yeah yes
sir um so anyways so someone tells them
that he's like hey you got to get in
good with the dad that's how you do it
so he's like okay he's gonna build this
relationship apparently he goes in and
he'd like it's like weird you know see
essentially the point is he forced it he
tried to force it so it didn't work so
in real life how that looks is like you
ever get like I don't know your friends
like a real estate agent or something
any sending you like handwritten notes
like hey just wondering how you're doing
it like Breyer I don't even know you
that good you know it's like so you
through obvious the ones you try to
force a good relationship you know and
it almost makes you kind of suspicious I
mean nowadays this is sure so it's
almost like it's called a brown-noser
and people consume it yeah if you're a
brown-nose yeah that's that's that's a
good point yeah but there's a dichotomy
with everything if you go so far
that all I'm looking to do is please
Dave with this conversation there's no
tension at all there's no there's
there's nothing and just me put being a
pushover well guess what what happens
with his respect for me it's respect a
little bit so I'm not talking about you
gotta be just a brown-noser at all yeah
yeah no no and then there's that's true
too but there's a nut and the one I was
thinking about or the type of person I'm
thinking about is like you can tell that
this person you're just trying to build
a relationship for me or with me I don't
know why I can suspect why maybe you
want my business or maybe you want
something you want something I know and
that's kind of at the forefront so I
mentioned this later in the book you
know how you just crush that I'll tell
you how you crush it when I'm talking to
Dave you know why I'm talking to Dave
you know why I want to build a
relationship because I care about Dave
yeah the number one thing for oh when
I'm talking to Dave Dave knows that you
know what I care about Dave if that's
the underlying if that's the underlying
principle on which we're that I'm doing
this is because I care about him he's
gonna know that it looks subconsciously
subconsciously and maybe sometimes you
got to be a little bit more proactive
and make sure that you know someone
understands it like I mean and it
doesn't mean proactive by saying hey
Dave I really care about you that
doesn't work you can't just say it yeah
I've got to prove by your actions you
got to show people like hey guess what's
more important than me you yeah so when
I'm talking to you and I'm listening to
you and I'm taking your advice on board
and I'm saying yeah you know what let's
go with your plan I'm doing that because
I want you to execute your plan I want
you to learn from your plan I want to
support your plan because I care about
you yeah that makes it actually that
that's good right there
that makes sense now so so it's almost
like actually it is where if I want to
build a relationship with Dave I'm not
gonna think okay let me focus on Bill
let me actively build a relationship
just out of the blue or out of nothing
it's like it's more like that's almost
in a way secondary well the first the
primary thing is like do I need to talk
to Dave then yeah I'll talk to Dave but
while I do that the point is to build a
relationship with them I'm not gonna be
like I need to build a relationship with
Dave where's Dave let me call him up and
start trying to build there
relationship with them yeah so you're
right
and there's there's a danger here that
your your someone's gonna be in court
courage to force right there impose good
relationships on people right so yeah
that you got to be careful Adams and and
again and actually here's the next line
in this book you are not building the
relationship so you can garner favor
from the boss know you're trying to
build a relationship so the boss trusts
you and will listen to you so you and
the team can more effectively accomplish
the mission yeah that's what you're
doing you want to accomplish the mission
which is good for everybody and then it
goes back and says for these reasons
choose your battle carefully because if
you remember this whole paragraph is
about like when do you actually approach
the boss when is it worth saying to the
boss hey hey boss can you explain this
to me because I'm not sure that I
understand what you want to have happen
here if it's not worth that conversation
because not gonna be that big of a
difference mm-hmm
just go with it you know just just go
with it but what I'm saying is like I
could see someone maybe reading this I
could see me reading it let's face it
I see me reading that and going to like
let's say I had a job and I could read
that and I'd be like hey all I mean
build a really super taco and then I'll
just roll in kinda out of the blue and
be like hey cuz I'm building my
relationship so I can garner trust
that's what I'm doing right now so this
is what I'm gonna do
hey joko did you catch that that
football game last night you're like
what are you talking about like you're
acting weird
here's the deal if the premise that you
go on in on is you want to build a
relationship with me for your own
benefit the I'm gonna see right through
that so does anybody else if the premise
that you go in is because you care about
me and you're wondering if I saw the
football game because you know I like
football and you want to talk to me
about it and you care about me yeah
that's gonna shine through and I'm not
gonna think this other negative thing so
yes if you're a person that's walking
around and you're gonna use the
principles in this book to benefit
yourself you know everyone's gonna see
through it it doesn't work and what's
really cool and this is all the like the
closing of the book is what we're
getting to right now is if you want to
if you want to have a successful run as
a leader and you want to rise to the top
the best possible way to do that is to
care about your team Carib
the mission take care of them and that
will show through and eventually you
will get to the top if you're if you're
sitting there thinking hey I want to get
to the top so I'm ready to do whatever
it takes and step on people or use
people it's it's so obvious yeah it's so
obvious when someone's playing in that
game and you can't barely even fake it
you can't barely even fake it like well
I'm look I'm gonna get to the top but I
know I have to be cool Dave my boss yeah
so I'm gonna manipulate here it's you
and here's the here's the really sad
thing if you're that person you think no
one can see it right everyone can see
yeah that's kind of the point there
where like you got to be careful with
that kind stuff where like if if I'm
trying to build a relationship like
brother can see what you're doing you
know spray like because again this is
Martin gotta be careful with it here's
how you be careful with it if you're
trying to do this for yourself it's not
gonna work if you're trying to do this
because you care about the team it's
gonna work and you're gonna win yeah you
personally are gonna win if you do this
if you do this because you want to win
you're gonna lose
yeah do this if you want to take care of
those people and you want the team to
win and you want them to accomplish the
mission so they can elevate yeah it will
work yeah yeah let's do huh I want to
win if you're if you're a young leader
right now listening to this conversation
and thinking about how you can build a
relationship and the power of the
relationship with your people actually
those individual how you interact with
that individual person isn't the biggest
thing because what those people and your
team are doing is watching you so maybe
jakka comes out and wants to build a
relationship with me and okay I'm trying
to figure out as the authentic or
genuine what I actually get to do is
watch Jaco with the other 10 dudes on
the team and over time if Jocko is just
how he is and he believes in that and
that actually he's gonna treat everybody
the same way and it's not gonna be what
he does or says to me that gets me to
buy off that he's on board of this as
I'm gonna see him in all the other and
everything else that he does I'm gonna
come to the conclusion like dude this is
legit that guy that guy - that guy cares
but everybody else being successful and
then those opportuni dyou at times and
there you will have opportunities to
build relations
but the authenticity isn't just what do
I say to echo to get echo to like me or
very favor with echo because actually
what you're doing to your leader is
you're watching everything that are
doing and the reason being fake about it
doesn't work isn't cuz I just see it
with me is I see you do with everybody
else that's why it's so obvious cuz
you're out there trying to figure how to
play the game with all these ten
different people and if you're if you're
faking it it it's gonna it's gonna be
completely obvious not because of how
you and I interact so the thing that
actually has to start with if you've now
put put in charge of a team or a leader
go back and read that second platoon
commander from chaco second platoon he
didn't walk in to go I'm honored to lead
you that count you as people that work
for me on my team he just said I'm happy
to be part of this and I'm happy to help
make this team win that's it you don't
need to elevate the statute everybody
knows who the bosses the chain of
command is understood everybody's got
that hierarchy what you actually need to
do is look for ways to break down those
barriers and just have them recognize
all this guy cares about is us winning
that's all he cares about and by
behavior after behavior after behavior
eventually you either doing it or you're
not and if you're doing it people gonna
get on board if you're not you're going
to fail no matter what you do and people
gonna see that a mile away smell it on
you mmm-hmm this continues on it is
obvious that building a trustworthy
relationship with your Spears is
important but how do you do that one of
the simplest ways is obvious but often
gets overlooked that is performance your
boss expects you just complete certain
tasks so complete them do them on time
on budget and with a little as little
drama as possible get the mission done
this includes doing things you might not
be 100% in agreement with I did this
throughout my career and it always
served me well boss wants me to fill out
some extra paperwork cool I'll do it
boss needs me to cover a shift for
someone else on the team I've got it
boss needs me to help clean up some
administrative mess that got spilled I'm
on it boss has a nasty low reward
mission that needs executing I'm all
over it with each one of those problems
I am the solution with each problem I
solve the level of trust with the boss
goes up and I will continue
on that path I won't complain or try and
shift bad jobs on to someone else or
even look for some kind of praise I will
simply put my head down and do the work
overtime my boss will know that I am the
person who can make things happen and
more important I gain clout with the
boss this is the opposite of the
subordinate who complains and objects or
always thinks he has a better way to do
things he loses influence with the boss
every time he opens his mouth any
objection from that subordinate is seen
by the boss as another typical excuse
the more you talk the less people listen
on the other hand when I do what needs
to be done the boss trusts that I can
make things happen
the boss also knows that if I do raise
an objection it is likely to be founded
on solid facts that should be considered
since I get things done and don't
constantly voice my objections the boss
actually listens
I always utilize this strategy with my
senior leadership and it worked well I
would simply make things happen as often
as I could now here's where this is
gonna I'm gonna preemptively shut down
your next comment echo Charles yeah
because I know I can already see from
this company where your head's at so
listen to this and this is this is where
I kind of feel like I make my money sure
right here on the next level okay but
how does that appear from the
perspectives of of your subordinates and
how everyone's looking at you go to use
do whatever the process for instance if
I recognize that there are some flaws in
my boss's plan then my subordinates
certainly recognize the same thing what
do I tell them how do I preserve their
respect if they think I can't see the
errors the boss is making the answer is
simple I tell them the truth
I say hey team I know there might be
some better ways to skin this cat but at
this point the effort to change the plan
would take almost the same effort that
it will to just get this job done so we
are just going to do it and let me tell
you what else we're doing by getting
this done we are building trust with the
boss every one of these little tasks
from him that we crush allows him to
trust us more and more and that gives us
the ability to get listened to so when
something comes up that really doesn't
make sense he will listen that is why we
are going to execute this plan to the
absolute best of our ability
there you go X which are your next
question just got preemptively answered
no more questions you're welcome
that's the part see that's the part
where people get worried and that's the
answer
okay worried what if the guy's gonna
think it yeah oh yeah and especially
when you and then when you say like
we're gonna build trust with the boss
it's like man that's like I have no
argument to that like what I'm sorry I
don't want to build trust with the boss
you know unless you're just some like
anti team member you know
and no one's no one's that really
anymore we don't want to be that but
yeah that's um
yeah that's good thank you you're
welcome
I skip to this section now called play
the game you have to play the game to be
more specific you have to play the long
game yes sir no one wants to hear this
especially from me people don't want to
hear about building relationships they
want me to say you achieve victory
through blunt force trauma if someone
gets in your way go through them any
political situation that is not turning
out how you wanted it can be solved with
a battle ax and this was a little thing
that would that was a problem in the
teams for me so if if somebody knew me
from like the periphery from like the
outside looking in kind of saw task unit
bruiser or saw my platoon or saw me at
traitor they would kind of get this idea
like okay you know this is this you
that's how jockle cut roles and
sometimes those guys would never get to
see the rest of the picture which was
which would not work out well and this
is something that lave talked about you
know life would see guys that he'd go
yeah they're they're trying to get their
jaakko on and they understand they
understand the what is the front facing
Jocko right the front facing taco they
don't understand the backside
and what's going on behind but in the
rear facing that type of hyper
aggressive take-no-prisoners mentality
is certainly simple and straightforward
which is often the kind of leadership
advice that people expect from me and
what they want to hear because that
attitude is so simple and
straightforward it hardly seems it could
fail and often that attitude doesn't
fail at least not at first a
heavy-handed and hostile approach
usually works for a little while you may
be able to bludgeon people into doing
what you want them to do for a day or
two maybe a week maybe even a solid few
months perhaps you can force a couple
projects to completion through ruthless
and aggressive offense but those
successes will be short-lived as you
trash relationships burn bridges and
leave scorched earth in your wake you
will soon look up and realize you are
done you have destroyed everything for
short-term gain you have nothing left
that last part is so important the chain
of command actually works and you can
utilize the chain of command all you
want you can get things done I can just
force the outcome I can if I am in
charge of you by rank or position or
title I can force that the lesson that
needs to take whit that will work until
it does it and then the results are
catastrophic they're not like a little
setback or maybe I gotta come up another
way when you go down that path when you
finally hit the end and you will I'd
maybe six months maybe a couple years
some guys get get by for a while they do
they get by long than we want them to
but when you get to the end and it stops
working then you're in catastrophe then
it's complete disaster and there's no
recovery from that so if you're going
down that road there is no easy end to
that as opposed to hey you know I work
through it and maybe hit a brick wall
and things don't work out I gotta take a
little bit of step back and things don't
work out the other approach that frontal
assault approach when it ends and I saw
throughout my career I watch guys hit
their limit some guys would be in a
matter of weeks and the first new
leading enlisted Marines first son
sometimes it happened to guys when they
were squadron commanders I mean they
made it a long way longer than they
should have yeah but eventually they hit
the wall well there's there's a reason
for that and that's as soon as you were
talking about this I was thinking the
read in the military
as I said earlier you get that job for
long enough to just barely start to
learn it and then you're on to another
job so what happens is it happens it
happens a lot in the military too often
a guy's just a guy that leads by
blunt-force trauma
and he he gets done with his you talk
about of the book there's like rest of
the guys in the squadron are willing to
take the abuse I don't care if my boss
is a jerk I'm actually gonna be
successful anyway and you got a bunch of
core guys in the squadron that have no
problem enduring that yeah if this guy
sucks but I don't care cuz I want to win
we're gonna be successful and they
actually benefit from that and he's gone
in 24 months right so this is what
happens and we see this as well you have
a person that was in the military that
rose through the ranks and did a good
job on paper but was abusive and blunt
force trauma down people on his rise up
retires from the military gets out of
the military and then all of a sudden
gets a job in a civilian sector and
doesn't last because as soon as he tries
that people are going wait a second hell
you think you're gonna be here for the
next ten years I'm not putting up with
this no no one in the chain of commands
putting up with this and then and then
you know what they say well you know
when I was in the military it was so
much easier who people are better they
all have that they have a million little
excuses that they tie into it everyone's
got this common goal everyone's already
been screened everyone's got their
million little things they respect the
chain of command it's like no actually
you're a bad leader you're a bad leader
being in the military and even getting
promoted through the military does not
by any stretch mean that you're a good
leader at all no no guarantee and this
is the type of person who gets done with
a platoon they get a good fit rep this
is another scary thing about this is
sometimes up the chain of command these
people look great from the people that
are above them they their boss loves
them their boss is like hey he got
everything done you know he's aggressive
really liked him you go into that
platoon and you guys you realize
or go into that unit and everyone goes
oh we hate that guy yeah but we're gonna
endure all right and we still and we are
going to endure him that he's only gonna
be here for 18 months or 24 months and
by the way we still care about our job
and we still have pride in our unit so
we're gonna make him look as good as we
can but we hate him yeah but we know we
can outlast him yeah we're over here
playing the long game
yeah don't care I hate him fine I'll
hate him but what I actually really want
is in the long run all my Marines are
all the people on my team I want them to
be successful so I'll play that day oh
and you know what if he gets promoted
looks good the only thing that will stop
me from playing the game working for a
boss that I hate and in Breaux I have
worked for bosses that I hate the only
thing that's gonna stop me from doing
that me too yeah
the only thing that stops me doing is my
own ego that's the only thing that keeps
me go you know what this guy sucks and
you know what I'm putting a stop to it
right now the only thing that that
forced me down that road is monitor you
go just keep it in check you were
playing the long game and you might get
not you might not get that satisfaction
of seeing him fall you might not get
that but if you were playing the long
game so you and your people are
successful it won't matter it won't
matter and it may take longer than you
want but it will not matter in the end
if you are indeed playing the strategic
game and so there's someone that's
listening right now going well oh my I'm
gonna let my boss abuse my people it's
like no no no actually not at all
however and there's a whole section in
this book that cover this oh if I got
someone that's abusing my people or
doing something half of an ethical
unsafe yeah maybe it is time for a mute
but and we'll get into that how you make
that decision of when it's time to
actually draw a line in the sand we'll
talk about that going back to this
section is you know talking about the
the person that just uses blunt force
trauma and I say don't do that instead
you have to play the game that means I
try to support my boss and perform my
duties to the best of my ability in
playing the game I am building up trust
with the boss I'm building a
relationship why is it so important to
build a relationship with my boss it is
it so I can get promoted it is it so I
can get assigned easier tasks no I am
trying
to build the relationship not for my own
personal gain I'm trying to build a
relationship with my boss so we can
better accomplish the mission and
playing the game doesn't only go up the
chain of command it goes down the chain
of command too when you are the boss and
your support you objecting to something
you say listen and ask for alternatives
and when they give you a decent one say
yes and utilize their alternative even
if their alternative doesn't seem quite
as effective or efficient as your
methodology let them do it this builds
trust and relationship with the people
below you in the chain of command as
often as you can listen and say yes
that's a nugget of beautiful advice
that's somebody say yes follow as often
as you can listen to your people and say
yes to what they are saying to you as
often as you can that's how you empower
people yeah that's how you build trust
with that's how you build a relationship
with them there are no 10 out of 10
plans they don't exist that Dave Burke
at the height of his career at Top Gun
never had a perfect plan there there is
no such thing as a perfect plan and your
idea is not perfect no matter how
experienced you are how smart you are
now their plan might be innate and yours
might be a nine point nine but the
deciding factor isn't the quality of the
plan the deciding factor is the person's
willingness to be successful when that
plan has a problem so if somebody has a
plan that's just barely good enough but
they really want to do it say yes
because what they're gonna do is gonna
hit a wall and they're gonna trying to
find a way to get over or around or
through that wall that's what they're
gonna do your plans are not perfect
neither are theirs so just go with their
plan as often as you can
continuing on eventually when a
subordinate from the team comes to you
with an idea that doesn't make sense you
can say no and they won't budge
but grudge you for it you simply explain
the issues with their idea and why you
aren't going to do it that way and they
will be okay with it they will accept
your direction without feeling that you
don't listen and they will move forward
with full commitment to accomplish the
mission I was getting there but this is
the little section on when is mutiny
in order and we just touched on this and
I give some good background on it and
then I say as we try and as we try and
work to get our boss to support what
we're saying right we make that effort
and I explained how to do that and then
we get to a point where I say okay but
even that doesn't always work sometimes
a boss digs in and will not change their
mind is it time for a mutiny is it time
to draw a line in the sand you could
tell your boss absolutely not
I will not do this your way it might be
time to say that but it also might not
be there are many variables to assess
and I talked about some of those
variables but that I jumped to I'm gonna
jump to here here are some possible
outcomes when the subordinate refuses to
comply so this is when you decide you
know what my boss came up with this plan
or my boss wants to do something and I
will not do it here's some things that
can happen one the leader recognizes
that the subordinate is extremely
concerned about the plan so concerned
they are putting their career at stake
and risking possible possible punitive
actions because the plan is actually
really bad this is the best possible
outcome the leader awakened by the
refusal of his or her subordinate to
execute a plan reconsiders the options
and decides to execute a different way
now the subordinate should rejoin the
team throw their support behind the new
plan and go help the team execute so
there's like the the flowery outcome you
know Dave orders me to do something I
say Dave I refuse to do this this is an
unsound plan and I will not execute and
Dave goes Wow
wow this must be a bad plan let me
reassess
okay Jocko explain it to me one more
time okay let's come up with a new plan
and then I say thanks Dave and we're
good that's the that's the best-case
scenario here's a possibility number two
the leader digs in even deeper and will
not change the plan since the
subordinate has refused to participate
the leader fires that subordinate and
puts a new leader in place who has been
hand
picked four unquestioning obedience for
the boss the problem is solved but the
team will absolutely suffer since now
the voice of reason has been replaced by
one of the bosses yes men it will be the
boss's plan and that is it no one will
have any choice or control this is a
horrible situation to avoid it consider
the fact that since the boss is refusing
to listen to suggestions about the plan
it is probable that the boss has a big
ego and is likely to put a yes-man in to
execute his or her vision without
resistance if this is a possible outcome
it must be weighed carefully so when
you're dealing with some of those like
I'm not listen to your plan as you need
to draw the line they're not like oh wow
chances are they're not now all of a
sudden ready to shift their mindset and
what are the attributes of a leader that
comes up with a plan that's utterly
catastrophic without committing it there
anybody and tells everybody this is the
plan super humble team player that's on
board for the big way that the type of
leader you're dealing with here yeah
it's bad continuing on if a subordinate
draws a line in the sand and refuses to
execute a plan or outright quits the
position as protests they instant
instantly remove all influence of any
kind over the boss so while the
subordinate has made a very loud and
clear statement once that statement has
been made there's nothing else they can
do they are no longer a factor in the
outcome and that's one of the you know
questions I have about david hackworth
s-- decision to be interviewed and state
in an interview that if we didn't change
the way we were fighting the war in
Vietnam we were going to lose when he
did that when he kind of drew a line in
the sand he was out of the army very
quickly out of command and that was that
which means he lost influence and let's
face it he would have been a general who
knows how high you would have gone but
he would have he would have been a
division commander you know I mean
eventually and then maybe he could have
influenced and moved the war in the
right direction but instead he drew a
line in the sand and he lost all of his
influence so now let's put ourselves in
david hackworth shoes right we love
soldiers we love the army
we love our men and our men we see we
see men in the army in the Marine Corps
throughout grunts being killed in
Vietnam and it breaks your heart every
single time and then he gets control of
his own battalion and he starts to save
their lives and they start to win but no
one else is doing it and with his heart
being broken over and over again he
can't take anymore says you know what
I'm drawn Ilan said can I see how that
could happen
oh absolutely so this is one of the
things that you have to weigh and think
about as a leader the last one if the
subordinate tries every possible method
to convince the boss that the plan is
wrong and sees no way of changing the
bosses mind then perhaps the better
option is for the subordinate to make
one last statement of concern and then
proceed to lead the team in the
execution of the plan to the best of
their ability
this way the subordinate leader can at
least do their utmost to mitigate the
negative impacts of the poor plan note
the harmful results so they can be
explained clearly to the boss and
continue to play the long game in
building a relationship with the boss so
they can convince the boss there is a
better way to execute going forward the
inherent risk is this in this of course
is that as Napoleon said the subordinate
is still culpable for the outcome
this is manda brothers banner brothers
dick winners they get order to do Rica
the wars all but over they get order to
do recon across the river they go do the
recon across the river they have a guy
get wounded they have a guy get killed
they come back the next night his boss
says do another recon and he says boss
not a good idea we didn't learn anything
last night however we did lose a guy and
another guy wounded and it could be even
worse I recommend we don't do it no do
the Recon boss not a good plan do the
Recon and what does dick winters do dick
winter says got it boss cool tells us
guys all right we're doing a recon
tonight of this basement over in this
building and bring some wine so
that's a classic example was that the
right thing to do
yes yes now if you would have quit and
said no I refuse to do this that that
lieutenant-colonel would have said cool
ok later dick winners yeah I got this
next guy he'll take Google he'll take a
recon over there tonight doesn't matter
so sometimes and you know I heard this
about seal platoons in Vietnam as well
getting tasked with doing a patrol or an
ambush in an area that was really bad
that they didn't feel like was gonna be
a fruitful ambush and get order to do it
and they're like hey Roger that Roger
that boss cool patrol out the gate go
200 meters into the jungle set up a set
up a perimeter sit there for six hours
come back say yup we didn't see anything
so is that ideal none but what are you
gonna do this this is these are the
things you have to consider as a leader
I've had in the military all the time
happens now all the time is people that
is that phrase falling on your sword and
I think most people understand I don't
think it's just military just the idea
of when are you gonna hold your ground
and when are you going to be willing to
to fall on your sword for whatever this
idea of this position that you think you
have and what you have to recognize I
think it's two things is when you do
that it's catastrophic for you that's
what the saying means it's catastrophic
for you but the other part is that that
comment you can that that Napoleon
comment was it doesn't that's not a free
pass for you the outcome is still yours
and it won't make you feel better
and it won't give you a sense of
accomplishment if you fall on your sword
and your team still ends up losing or
something catastrophic happens just to
say well I I held my ground and I told
the boss we're not doing it and you get
removed you get a counter manager or or
worse you get fired or something really
the outcome is still yours and again
the piece that drives people more often
to do that is is your ego convincing
yourself that what I'm being asked to do
is is catastrophic
there are times that's actually true
sometimes you get orders that are wrong
they are kept they will
catastrophic and that story you know the
the dick the dick winter story there
that when they lost that guy
the real question was this is a waste
this is a wasted life this was something
we shouldn't have done because it had no
real benefit that not as catastrophic
but more often than not when we get
asked to do things that we think are
wrong if we can actually detach a little
bit and think okay what is the worst
outcome of this is it really
catastrophic is it really worth falling
under sort or if you stay in position
can you exert enough control that you're
the reason why it is not catastrophic
that you are the one that prevents the
potential catastrophe from happening and
the answer that has almost never is it
actually can almost never and even if it
is the most influential thing you have
to prevent the kassak catastrophe is
your leadership and that's hard I think
for a lot of people's like because
following and restored has this it's
like a cliche that people almost want to
do well you get to be the Margaret yeah
you're the martyr and yeah that and also
how often are you failing as a leader to
articulate the issues well enough with
your boss that they actually understand
so instead of trying to formulate a
better argument for your boss to
understand what you're trying to say you
just say well he doesn't get I'm gonna
follow my sword I mean how often you
know why is it so rare that it's
catastrophic because how often is a boss
getting told that there's going to be a
catastrophic outcome hey boss I think if
we open this building if we if we get a
lease on this building we try and we try
and set up shop there I think we're
gonna lose a lot of money and we're
gonna burn a bunch of our employees and
it's gonna be a complete and utter
catastrophe and the boss is like hey I
still like it go right or in the
military hey I boss I am very concerned
that we are gonna take heavy casualties
and there will be no gain and the boss
goes no I like it go ahead yeah I've
never even had a boss do anything even
close to those things now could it be
hey you I want you guys to approach the
target from here well boss I don't agree
with that well I'm telling you to do it
okay well how catastrophic is that guess
what I'm gonna do I'm gonna get on site
amaura gave us
you know they passed the pro word that
that that Avenue of approach was blocked
and we're now approaching from where I
planned a problem but I wouldn't say
that but I'd say now we're gonna have to
approach from a different direction
sorry did you say pro word Pro path the
pro pro word yeah they're just words
that like they're like code words
yeah and they and it's not like they're
a secret but you might want to tell the
upper chain of command that we have
passed through phase line red and we are
now approaching the target building and
instead of saying all that you just say
you know Chevrolet and they go to Grover
yep the reality is that that first
scenario with this this boss wants the
catastrophe the reality is is that it
almost never happens and almost no and
the likelihood that it's happening to
you is almost zero I'm not saying it's
it's not zero but it can happen it can't
happen it can't happen and in it in
those cases you may you have to fall on
yes and say I refuse to do this that's
right
that second scenario happens all the
time
all the time and actually that's the one
that you should be planning for the how
to manage that all the time which is
that man this is actually not a good
plan and you know what I'm in the ideal
position to mitigate all the risk
associated with it and I'm going to do
exactly that hey boss we're gonna
complicate mission let's go make that
happen and then do like you said all
those things what you should be planning
for is is that second scenario because
that's gonna happen throughout your
career all the time scenario number one
almost never yeah
don't think it ever happened to me and I
would say it's a pretty good statement
because I think I would remember if it
did I'm gonna think about this though
I'm gonna think about if it ever if I
ever got ordered to do something that I
was in complete and utter disagreement
with especially something that's not in
training I've had some pretty bad
training plans yeah those are training
but those are training plan so whatever
in my real you know real combat
situations I would have to put some
thought into even what I think even
comes even close to what even was close
yeah
all right well did some and I just took
that thought one step further did I
sometimes hear some crazy plans coming
down the channel yeah and then I would
say hey boss this is crazy for the
following reasons the boss is it oh cool
thanks for pointing that out don't do it
pretty pretty straightforward I didn't
worry you know boom all right skipping
forward to another section here the
section is called subordinate your ego
which is a good phrase powerful phrase
may I actually go through a pretty
detailed example of when I had to
subordinate my own ego and how that
helped solve this certain problem and I
end up kind of going into an explanation
of what the ego is how it's playing out
granularly here we go back to the book
ego is like reactive armor the harder
you push against it the more it pushes
back do I get some good credit for that
one that is hankers out there out
appreciated that is and that is it that
is so true yes someone someone that
doesn't someone that's got an ego like
you might not even notice until you
brush up against them good all of a
sudden reacts continues on if I had
confronted the CEO and that goes back to
the story if I had confronted the CEO
about his attitude and told him he had a
big ego he would have dug in even deeper
so I did the opposite i disarmed his ego
by subduing my own now this is why I
wanted to bring this up today you might
be afraid that if you subordinate your
ego you will get trampled but that
normally doesn't happen because
subordinating your ego is actually the
ultimate form of self-confidence and I
think that line right there is one of
the lines when I was writing this book I
just like took a screenshot of it and
texted it to you damn I was like that
line right there if because
subordinating your ego is actually the
ultimate form of self-confidence that
level of confidence earns respects earns
respect so while the initial thought or
feeling might be that you
back down you've actually shown that you
have the strength and confidence to give
the other person credit and they will
recognize and respect that confidence
either consciously or subconsciously
they feel it they feel it echo Charles
when you're getting ready to roll
jujitsu MMA and you have never rolled
with this person before and you lock up
with them you know right you can feel it
and now whether you want to admit it or
not you know yeah and that's what this
does when someone says hey you know
let's go ahead and run with that and
Dave might think we that's right that's
right I'm gonna run with it cuz my
planners been and in the back of his
mind he thinks man yeah like when
someone says oh you want to start a
cross side that's basically what you're
saying that's basically what you're
saying yeah you want to start in a
dominant position to go ahead it's fine
it's fine with me I'm so confident in my
jujitsu that you can basically start
anywhere you can start a totally
dominant position and I'm gonna be fine
and when you subdue your ego and you
subordinate your ego that person now
that person you might be thinking oh oh
yeah I'm gonna start on the mountain I'm
gonna kill you and you think that right
and you feel powerful but in the back of
your mind you're thinking oh yeah maybe
subconsciously you're thinking wow this
person is confident this person knows
that they're gonna win you know and so
that's the same thing that happens here
hey you know what won't you take don't
you go ahead and run with this hey yeah
that's right I won and in the back your
mind you think man job jock who doesn't
even really yeah he doesn't even care
what this ends up the word subordinate
is such a good word because when you
tell people to check your ego it's like
okay I could check my ego but if you're
the type of person that reads the word
subordinate and it bothers you yeah you
are the person that's being spoken to
you right now because your ego says I am
not gonna support because it's
submissive or has this feeling of that's
why that word is actually so good
because most of us don't want to do that
they don't like I don't like that word
suborning I don't want to suborn eight I
don't want to be submissive or passable
but that word is awesome because if you
feel yourself right now reading that
going I don't like that read this again
and again anything cuz that's actually
what you need to do
and check us out if you're reading this
and you're going I don't want to
subordinate my ego because I'm powerful
then read the next part which says if
you're truly powerful you got no problem
that I don't yes what hey you know what
I don't need to be the I don't need to
be the star of the show cuz I'm just
gonna be over here and it's gonna be
fine you guys can you you can you can
pay attention to the other guys that's
cool I'll be over here just and I'm good
with that I don't need to say anything I
don't need to start in the best position
I'm good
I'm confident I've been doing this game
for a long time we're good
it continues on so after I say either
come they will recognize and respect
that confidence either consciously or
subconsciously it says and that is the
truth to put your ego in check to
subordinate your ego you must have
incredible confidence if you find you
cannot put your ego in check because
you're afraid it might look might make
you look weak then guess what you are
weak
don't be weak subordinate your ego build
relationships and win the long game
that's a pretty important chapter in
this book that's huge I mean that gets
to the core of what infects almost
everything we do there almost isn't a
problem in the world that exists in your
life that isn't connected to your ego
and that is the lesson for that and the
amazing thing about that is that not
only are you strong if you can do that
you just start winning everywhere you
start waiting everywhere in life you
just start winning when you do that when
you're looking to go oh no no factor go
for it do that though you win
life gets so much better when you're
able to do that just let it go and the
supreme confidence this is the weird
part so people understand the supreme
confidence that that exudes when you go
oh you want to take lead on this cool go
for it
cool yeah what can I do to help yeah
what can I do to support you sounds like
it sounds like you got this handled what
can I do to help the supreme confidence
that that exudes
is is powerful kind of like when someone
gets in your head on the map right yes
we they go oh you can start wherever you
want right I'll tell you even more
powerful moment smaller it's seemingly
smaller but it's way more powerful when
you think about it so let's say me and
you're rolling right and then you uh let
let's say I get a good position on you
right and you um and then we sort of
drew and let's say get Mount whatever
good great position on you and we sorted
we're scrambling whenever I still got
them out and then we kind of drift out
of bounds right or we run into somebody
or whatever we got to kind of stand up
you know get out of the jujitsu position
set up and walk to a clear part on the
mat and then so cuz that'll happen
sometimes in the person in the bad
position we'll just sort of clap your
hand like you're starting all over
oh yeah that's even yeah you see they'll
be like oh yeah we're we're all gonna
see maybe a small adjustment maybe I
like oh like you're mounted but I got my
elbow already in so it's gonna be okay
yeah that's a little bit more sneaky
yeah you know I mean it's probably just
as sneaky but just in a different way
it's a different thing in a little bit
of it well that both they're both gonna
send the same message yeah
but scared but this exactly right so
here's what not confident yeah exactly
right so let's go one step further so
let's say we roll I get into a good
position on you we go back to the center
thing you slapped my hand and you get
into like the the neutral position right
and it's like a little dance you know
someone someone's gonna lead this and
least lead that right so you some hand
we get into a neutral position the
confident guy would just be like cool
really neutral position yeah yeah cool
and we just keep rolling oh yeah the
uncomfortable wait I had my ID not know
let's go back to Mountain you know if
you'd still be justified but the
supremely confident because it's like oh
I'll tell you what why don't you mount
me don't say anything just be like
whatever is what we're doing I don't
even I don't need it I don't need
attention to to let you know that that's
how supremely confident I am you know
they seem saying like it Mike I'm so
confident I had a head mount I'll let it
slide you know just do it never be that
guy be that guy 100% all right moving on
to this next section core tenets the
first one is called
be capable and ask for help a leader
must know and understand the jobs skills
and equipment used by the people below
him or her in the chain of command this
isn't to say a leader needs to be an
expert in everything that is impossible
the team commander does not know as much
about shooting as his snipers do he
can't understand the various radios as
well as his radio man does he will not
know the details of routes to and from a
target like the point man will on a
construction site the foreman won't be
able to operate the equipment with the
same efficiency as those who operate
that equipment all day long you won't be
able to lay block as well as the Masons
or tie rebar like an iron worker in the
manufacturing business a plant manager
might not be able to run each machine or
handle every task on the line but in
these cases the leader must at least be
familiar with what goes on below him in
the chain of command
what should a leader do if he doesn't
know or understand a skill or job that
plays a role in the accomplishment of
the mission simple ask that's right go
and ask and not just for an explanation
asked ask to learn and actually do sight
in that sniper weapon program that radio
lay some block run that piece of
equipment for a little while get
familiar and then actually practice the
task unfortunately most people avoid
this process because they have feet they
fear they will look stupid they think
their subordinates will lose respect for
them but the opposite is true this is
another area where ego can be a real
impediment to success some leaders feel
it is a weakness for at to ask for help
that couldn't be further from the truth
sabore nets will actually respect the
leader more if they come and try to
learn and perform the task
what subordinates don't respect is a
leader who tries to appear to know
everything I know this from experience
when I was a junior ranking seal I was
always impressed by a boss who would
come and truly show interest in what we
were doing on the frontlines
I was even more impressed if they asked
questions and wanted to really
understand my perspective and I would be
completely impressed if the leader
physically tried to do what I was doing
program a radio shoot and advanced
weapons system or build a demolition
charge if you need help with something
ask for it sabor
it's understand that their leaders might
not know everything put your ego in
check and ask for help you will do a
better job and you will gain respect
from your team stepping down and
learning frontline skills also shows
your humility it proves you aren't above
what the frontline troops are doing and
it shows you know their job is hard
seems that common sense it does seem
like common sense and I see that very
rarely in certain leaders in the private
sector and I think it's exactly what you
said there's this fear of looking dumb
when I would had my first real job in
the Marine Corps I had a who's called
power line at 38 Marines it's a big
position for a lieutenant as a young
officer at 38 Marines and their job was
to essentially service the engines of
the aircraft and make sure the Jets were
good to take off and land it was a huge
responsibility and there's a
qualification to get that and when I
took over that job I got that
qualification which was not really what
I was designed to do but I wanted to do
it to learn so I learned all the things
that I needed to know and I got this
designation this qualification to be
able to do this launch and recovery is
that normally an enlisted guys job it is
it isn't illicit guys but I wanted it's
my first job I wanted to know what I
want to know what they were doing and
guess what we had 24 plane captains in
the squadron I was the worst one by far
I was terrible at it and I didn't have a
ton of experience a ton of history but
not just what I learned from doing it
but the connection I made with those
guys that I was just willing to do that
and it isn't like some gesture of hey I
want to spend it it's actually learn
what's going on in their world it made
me so much smarter because I understood
what the problems were they were dealing
with getting down with your folks if
you're gonna do it just to kind of put
on a good show
don't don't waste your time but if
you're actually willing to go down there
and look stupid the youth their respect
for you will go because because most
people are gonna do it we'll go off the
charts and it seems so obviously such
common sense and it says is this
actually easy thing to do okay it is
counterintuitive
even though it seems common sense from
us looking at it right now it's super
counterintuitive because you think well
I don't really know how to do the job so
hide from it so that way would they
won't know and I won't look bad had to
had to throw this in there one of the
most important tenets of leadership I
adhere to as a leader is the idea of
extreme ownership the idea of extreme
ownership has struck a chord with people
and it has been incredibly infective
effective in helping those in all kinds
of leadership positions leading all
kinds of teams in all kinds of
industries businesses and professions
leaders found that when they took
ownership of everything in the world
they saw other members of their teams
both up and down the chain of command
taking ownership as well when people
take ownership for their jobs and their
mission the job gets done and the
mission gets accomplished when there are
problems and people take ownership of
those problems the problems get solved
while extreme ownership might seem like
a fairly simple concept to understand it
can be difficult to fully comprehend
what it really means what it really
means is that the leader is responsible
for everything absolutely everything
this can be hard to fully understand
because there are times when a
subordinate does something that the boss
feels they cannot control and cannot
possibly be responsible for a
subordinate might make a mistake or take
an action that is completely unexpected
how can that be the leaders fault I like
to use the example of a young machine
gunner in a seal platoon to exemplify
how a leader truly is responsible for
everything that happens a seal machine
gunner plays a key role in a seal
platoon as the name implies he carries a
machine-gun a heavy belt-fed weapon
capable of firing over 700 rounds per
minute the machine guns ability to lay
down such massive firepower makes it
critical to a seal platoon or squad
because it is the main weapon that puts
down suppressive fire on the enemy it
keeps the enemy's heads down allowing
the rest of the seals to maneuver the
machine gun provides the main source of
cover in the fundamental tactic of cover
and move the first law of combat of
course the machine gun doesn't operate
itself it's worthless without the
machine gunner the machine gunner
carries the weapon and its ammunition
maintains the weapon loads who fires the
weapon those are the mechanics of the
job but a machine gunner must also be
aware of how to best employ his weapon
he must understand how to get in good
position from which
to best engage the enemy and provide
cover for his team he must also
understand the terrain he is in and see
how it can be used to his advantage and
to the advantage the platoon and how the
enemy can also use the terrain to their
advantage if allowed to do so the
machine gunner must also understand his
field of fire field of fires the area of
the battlefield a seal is responsible
for whether a street hallway Valley or
cardinal direction in that area he must
locate locate and engage the enemy but
field of fire is equally important in
its limitations outside one's field of
fire there might be innocent civilians
other friendly forces or perhaps even
your own seals bluntly stated staying
within your field of fire prevents you
from shooting your own people so the
machine gunner can have a lot on his
mind but because his job is to shoot
that generally isn't much leadership
required from him machine gunners are
almost always part of a small fire team
of four to six people which is led by a
fireteam leader with the lack of
leadership opportunities being a machine
gunner is a job that is generally held
by relatively inexperienced new guys who
are in their first or maybe second
platoons because of the size of the
machine gun it is also often referred to
as the pig which makes the machine
gunner a pig gunner also because of the
size the pig gun it usually requires a
SEAL who's slightly larger to carry it
while it is not always true is common
for new guys to be assigned as pig
Gunners if they are large framed strong
individuals there is also an ongoing
stereotypical joke in the SEAL Teams
that pig Gunners being big strong new
guys aren't the sharpest tools in the
shed any new guy that does something
dumb will be told he will make a good
pig gunner when a briefing is completed
it would not be uncommon for the platoon
chief to ask do you Pig Gunners
understand this is why the stereotypical
pig gunner makes the perfect example of
extreme ownership because the
stereotypical pig gunner is going to
make mistakes and they are a very easy
target for blame I heard it on a fairly
regular basis from young seal leaders on
training operations that I ran the young
leaders didn't fully understand their
roles and the concept of extreme
ownership the training operations I ran
were very
plexins stressful in combat and stress
will combat simulations we had a large
budget for training and we utilized it
to replicate the chaos mam of combat to
the best of our ability we hired
Hollywood set designers to make our
training areas look like cities in Iraq
or Afghanistan we use role players to
mimic the actions of both enemy
combatants and friendly civilians we
simulated weapons with paintball or
other high-end paint marking rounds or
with multi-million dollar laser tags
system this simulated combat zone not
only taught tactics it was the ultimate
leadership laboratory and this is where
I would see young seal leaders reveal
that they didn't understand what extreme
ownership really meant let's say your
pig gunner let's say a young Pig gunner
shot his weapon in the wrong direction
outside his field of fire when I would
ask the pig Gunners leader what had gone
wrong it was very easy for him to say
well the pig gunner made a mistake he
shot in the wrong direction whose fault
is that
I would ask well the gunner aimed the
weapon he pulled the trigger it is his
fault
would be the reply actually I would
explain it's your fault how could it be
my fault he's the one that shot the
weapon the young leader would object
this was a pretty common response but it
was wrong
you see if the pig gunner makes a
mistake it means he hasn't been trained
properly the leader is responsible for
training the gunner if the gunner shoots
in the wrong direction it means he
hadn't been briefed so he fully
understands his field of fire the
leaders responsible for briefing the
gunner and yes it could also mean the
pig gunner is completely incompetent in
understanding his task and knowing his
field to fire if that is the case is the
leaders responsibility to identify that
shortfall and either train the gunner so
he does understand remove the gunner
from his position and place him into a
job he is capable of or as a last resort
fire the gunner from the team so he
can't if he cannot do his job properly
so regardless of the reason if gunner
failed it is the leaders fault a leader
is responsible for everything a person
on his or her team does I even felt like
this when one of my guys would get in
trouble off base if one of the SEALs who
worked for me went out in town and drank
too much and got into a fight I always
thought where did I mess up how did I
fail to
that individual realized that
consequences of his actions why didn't I
know he was headed for trouble and keep
him from going out taking extreme
ownership means that leaders are
responsible for every action the people
on their team make it is as simple as
that you might wonder why I had to put
that section in there but we hear this
all the time yeah it's not really my
fault I mean I get it oh yeah of course
I'm responsible but but hey he's not
that good but no the marketing
department
I know it's my responsibility they
released something that should have been
released you know it's my fault but I'm
gonna fire that person okay it's not my
fault it's their fault it means
everything and then we get into this
pre-emptive ownership when a leader
knows they cannot blame anyone or
anything else they will implement what I
call pre-emptive ownership they will
take ownership of things to prevent
problems from unfolding in the first
place
the leader who knows he can't blame his
machine gunner when the machine gunner
makes a mistake is going to take
pre-emptive ownership and focus on
training that machine gunner and
ensuring he understands the plan and his
part in it the leader who knows bad
weather is no excuse not to execute a
mission we'll take pre-emptive ownership
to ensure there are layers of
contingency plans in the event the
weather takes a bad turn the same is
true for any team if the leader knows
there truly are no excuses then he or
she will make every conceivable effort
to prepare ownership isn't just about
taking responsibility when mistakes
happen
the highest form of extreme ownership of
extreme ownership takes place
preemptively before mistakes occur so
don't just take extreme ownership after
the fact take pre-emptive ownership to
mitigate problems before they even
happen
some people don't make that connection
extreme ownership is not only in the
past tense it actually is the present
tense and future tense yeah there's also
a reason why this is in the strategy
section of this is it this is this is
sort of the highest level of the mindset
of if you really believe everything is a
default if you really believe that not
with a little caveat or like well in
this case if you can take the foot out
of it and it's just it's just my fault
period if you actually have that frame
of mind genuinely and you actually truly
believe that this idea of pre-emptive
ownership was actually really easy
because you just start to look for
things well in advance of what pitfalls
are gonna come and doing this isn't as
hard as it is it might sound the the
barrier isn't taking pre-emptive
ownership the barrier is actually
believing that there are no little
exceptions to where it's actually not
your fault that's the piece that's hard
for folks and it's hard everywhere sorry
the military of TARP in the private
sector it's hardened families but when
you see the ones that do it this thing
that you just talked about they're
people doing all the time the ones that
truly are there that's all they're doing
is looking for it for those for those
places ahead of time those people
ironically are the most successful their
plans are the ones that achieve the
highest amount of success because
they've they're way out in front of all
those potential pitfalls you got to
throw a dash of you got to throw a dash
of long game strategy into this because
if what I do is okay there's no excuses
Dave you're running this mission cool
I'm gonna direct and I'm gonna but I'm
gonna micromanage you to the point where
I promise there will be no mistakes okay
I now this is why I gotta throw some
long game and there are some strategic
vision that's why it's in the strategy
section because if that's what I do what
have you learned you haven't learned you
haven't figured out how to plan on your
own you haven't figured out how to
execute the operation on your own so
even though you're responsible for
everything which you absolutely are that
doesn't mean that you do everything and
by the way you
do everything you don't have no time or
the cognitive capacity to handle and
make every decision you can't do it
so taking extreme ownership of
everything doesn't mean doing everything
yourself and micromanaging and making
every decision at all that's a
short-term and like a like we said
earlier that's like a brute force thing
it can work for a little while like I
could be like okay Dave oh you're going
to talk to a company cool I'm gonna go
with you I'm gonna write your brief for
you I'm gonna you know sit in the back
row and make adjustments as you talk
okay cool
I can do that one time what about Mike
Cirelli who's out there what about
Andrew Paul I'm not gonna do it for
everyone
what about Flynn what about Lynn am I
gonna sit there and did no can't do it
it's impossible to do so
yeah I'm responsible for what we're
saying I'm a responsible for our mission
but I gotta make sure that the training
is happening that the knowledge is there
and then you got to take a step back
speaking of which I'm jumping to this
section called leading from the rear one
of the most common mantras that leaders
here is lead from the front and it makes
sense after all some critical things
happen when leaders lead from the front
when a leader leads from the front he or
she is setting the example showing
exactly what to do and how to do it this
model can be critical during
fear-inducing moments there are many
examples in combat where the situation
is dire and it is leadership from the
front that changes the outcome perhaps
there is an perhaps there is some open
terrain to cross maybe there is an enemy
sniper waiting to take a shot maybe
there is a room with enemy fighters
behind the door that needs to be entered
any of these scenarios can cause people
to become fearful and freeze who wants
to risk death but any of these
situations any of these situations can
grow infinitely worse if no action at
all is taken most types of combat
examples prove that someone needs to act
more often than not that someone is the
leader when no one else has the courage
to take action the leader has to lead
from the front the leader has to charge
across the open terrain maneuvering in
the enemies snipers line of fire or
breach the door to engage enemy fighters
if the leader doesn't take action no one
will the troops will freeze the enemy
will seize the initiative get the upper
hand and went it is not only combat
situations where leaders need to lead
from the front
in any situation that is stagnated
because of fear or apprehension a leader
stepping up and taking action is a solid
solution the same is true of terribly
arduous tasks people tend to shy away
from suffering they will procrastinate
and avoid getting started but when the
leader jumps in and starts attacking the
job others will jump in and get started
as well a leader must also lead from the
front when it comes to setting a good
example treating people with respect
taking care of one another and being
professional at all times if the leaders
lead in this manner others will follow
examples like these prove there are
plenty of times when a leader must lead
from the front
but there are also times when the leader
must lead from the rear or perhaps from
the middle so plenty of times where a
leader has to lead from the front that
absolutely makes sense I've seen it I've
done it it happens but back to the book
when I served as a seal assault force
commander I always tried to avoid being
one of the first six to eight people to
potentially to enter a potentially
hostile building during an assault I did
this because the first six to eight
people would be clearing rooms perhaps
getting in gunfights and at a minimum
detaining potentially resistant
prisoners in short the first six to
eight people would be heavily engaged in
dynamic fluid situations that required
their full attention
if those first assaulters got into a
firefight and were immersed in trying to
stay alive and eliminate the enemy who
would call for supporting assets if they
were overwhelmed by a large number of
detainees who would call for
reinforcements if possible enemy
personnel were seen departing the
building who would notify the external
security elements that this was
happening in any of those cases while
the assault team was dealing with the
immediate tactical problem someone else
had to lead in those situation it was in
those situations it was on me to lead my
job was not to clear rooms engage
targets or grapple with detainees my job
was to detach assess all the dynamics of
the situation and get my men the support
they needed so when I approached a
building if I happen to end up as one of
the people toward the front of the
assault team I would step back
hi port my weapon and let some of the
other seals go in front of me as soon as
my seal saw me do that they immediately
knew what was happening and
move past me toward the target the
momentum would not be broken but is not
only on the battlefield where a leader
has to be cautious about leading from
too far to the front planning is another
time it is important to consider where
to lead from instead of the leader
coming up with a plan
the preferred method is to let the team
members come up with a plan let it be
their idea when the leader allows the
team members to come up with a plan
those members have already bought into
it there is no need to convince them of
it of course if the planning process
gets bogged down or different members of
the team can agree on a course of action
it might be necessary for the leader to
step in and provide guidance or even
make a decision on which course of
action to use so and it just closes this
out but it is almost always preferred
for the leader to lead from the rear to
allow the troops to take lead on the
plan and to take ownership of the best
ideas often come from the people on the
team who are closest to the problem
those are the folks on the frontline
don't inhibit them instead allow them
the freedom and authority to create an
and execute new plan some ideas they
have the knowledge give them the power
don't feel the need to always lead from
the front take a step back and let your
team lead yeah it's you know Dave you've
been working with me long enough that
you probably see me how long how long
we've been working together now three
years three years you probably see me
I'm gonna guess seven times in three
years you know have something going on
and me say all right here's what we're
doing do you what do you think is that a
good assessment yeah seven or less seven
seven or lesson this is a lot of things
a lot of things I mean hundreds and
hundreds of decisions yes that get made
an echelon front and seven times yeah
it's been contentious enough or bogged
down enough where it's like okay well
now we're not actually making progress
and nothing's happening and it's like
okay guys here's what we're doing and
you know it's the same thing that women
when I was on a ground force commander
an assault force coming
I wasn't gonna say anything cuz the guys
knew what to do and then occasionally
they didn't know what to do and when I
talked people listened it's that I think
more than then it being contentious or
bogged down it's actually the few times
where like you know what damn I don't
know what to do here and that little
vacuum that gets created is when you
step in typically not when you know it's
it's not like me and Flynn are arguing
or we're late on our arm wrestling over
something you're gonna come in and
adjudicate it it's actually when you see
oh you know what there's a there's a
place that that that these guys Dave
isn't actually no to do here progress is
not yeah that's right we're not moving
in the direct and and and I'm gonna step
in and do that for him or for the team
or whatnot and then you know typically
this they after a conversation is hey
there are some things I could have
explained or there's a way that I could
have set you up to be more successful
and that that situation but this the
common of it's almost always preferred
to leave from the rear that is met with
heavy resistance we use a version of
that I explain that to the key you know
when we work in a lot of companies a lot
of times were working with really senior
leaders c-suite you know executives CEOs
high level in the organization they
don't like the idea of not leading from
the front and what they typically
complain about the most is that they
don't have enough time to do anything
and it's always that they can't get
everything done that they want to get
done and it's for that reason alone is
that they're in charge of everything
which is why they don't have time and
why their teams are underperforming or
why they're struggling what and why they
need that help
but that common of don't you know that's
preferred a lot of times to not be in
the front is there's a kind of that
immediate reaction I don't like the way
that sounds you have to explain what
that means there cuz it because you get
told that all the time all that I mean
how how common is the frayed lead from
the front lead from the front day one
Marine Corps training lead from the
front day one especially an officer
training like that is it from from the
beginning and you know we are you know
complimented on you know this this Iron
Mike he's out in front he's got his arm
up he's pointed with the weapon it's the
follow me you know mantra mindset that's
all throughout military training and
just like you described it doesn't mean
that you don't have to say
but do that but when you were actually
supposed to do that is when there's a
vacuum and avoid that's what you go hey
I have to get out in front of this that
happens if your people are well-trained
and resourced that doesn't actually
happen very often it actually happens
about seven times every three years is
kind of the rate that you should be
thinking that you need to be out front
because of the rest of time if you're
actually doing your job those vacuums
voids aren't there now if you're
adjudicating conflict those are those
might be some other things but it's
really the vacuums of decisions when
you're people like you know what boss I
gotta be honest with you I don't know
what to do here or you see or feel that
is where you need to get out front that
doesn't happen all that often
yeah which also means as you said
earlier what the minute I have to go
okay here's where we need to go I'm 20
seconds later I'm thinking myself okay
they I'm not doing a good job of
explaining the intent here that's right
and the team is right yeah this is this
is this is on me and I need to make that
more clear which usually that whatever
situation unfolded is a real opportunity
to say hey look this is what this is
what we need to do and here's why yeah
the next time we see this we know what
to do
and if you've cultivated all these other
things that we've been talking about
that you wrote about here those times
that you is the leaders step in your
team doesn't resent it and they're not
annoyed or frustrated with you they're
thankful and they're glad so the
explanation is way easy it's a huge
deposit and and you don't have to worry
about doing those things because nobody
pushes back on it they're actually
relieved man I wasn't hitting a brick
wall here and and that's actually what I
needed as opposed to he's in my business
and tell me what to do which is the
exact opposite of what you're talking
about here which actually happens if you
think you need to be in front all the
time what you're doing more often than
not 93% of the time you're stepping on
people's toes and you're and you're
hurting them in the long run yeah rather
let them be successful yeah I've got we
can cover it I got a whole section in
there on when to step up and lead like
when do you actually have to fill that
leadership vacuum how do you do it and
this is another one of those things that
as I reflected upon I was like yeah
here's what I'm so obvious to me but
never really articulated it because
never really had the never really got
asked that
God asked that pointed of a question she
never got asked how do you you know how
do you shoot that weapon where do you
put your hand where do you put your
shoulder on that 240 Gulf when you're
engaging from a bipod I never got asked
wait when is it yeah everyone just sees
you do it and they just think okay well
I kind of get that but no you need to
write that stuff down yeah for sure this
is a section that that you were talking
about earlier today the the section is
called don't care and it's a form of
detachment and then people know about it
because of the idea of negotiations you
know the ability to walk away from
negotiations oh you don't want to you
don't lower your price of cool yeah I'm
wearing this - oh yeah um but it it's
something that you can use as a leader
if you drill down going to the book if
you drill down on things you care about
you will find that many of them are
rooted in ego even the simplest examples
so like when you're a leader not caring
as a powerful tool you want to utilize
your plan instead of mine cool I don't
care you wanna you want me to do some
crappy job for you that others find a
meeting fine I don't care oh you want me
to give someone else the opportunity to
lead a project awesome I don't care and
then I'll give them a bunch of support
that that's what it is and then once
again this kind of ties back into this
idea of like this supreme level of
confidence which is when you can put
your ego in check when you can
subordinate your ego it's because you're
so you have confidence yeah and not
caring when you're supremely confident
is different than not caring yes it's
totally different yeah yeah those are -
those are those are like clickbait
titles aren't they don't care and lead
from the rear yeah those are clickbait
titles
I just realized maybe I'll have to make
mideco can you make a you know couple
videos with those don't care yeah and
lead from the rear yeah there you go
clickbait but to your point even though
they sound clickbait yeah and they and
they almost I mean can you imagine going
in the Marine Corps I mean like okay
lead from the rear and don't care look
that's the opposite of everything that
you do everything later
yeah
so and and not to mention we talked for
already 20 minutes today about the
fundamental thing that you're doing as
leaders caring about your people so yeah
you have to read and fully understand
what we're talking about here yes in
that section you get to read all those
because the idea of when you say I don't
care about you asking me to do a
demeaning to ask them it means I'll do
anything I don't care what it is because
I'm here to help the team win not the
passive-aggressive don't care and not
caring it was fun the last muster in
Australia there was a lot of this going
on and it was cool because yeah we know
we rewind three or four monsters ago and
all of a sudden someone saying I want my
slide here or hey I want to use this
font or you know I I need this much time
to cover this topic and this time I it
was just hey how much time do you do you
need to cover that I don't care I
remember there was some conversation and
I think Jamie was like hold on she was
doing the calculation for how much time
each person gets free slot and she said
wait choco this thing that I gave you 45
minutes can you cover it it actually
turns out to be only 20 minutes and I
was like cool okay
like it literally doesn't matter yeah
the only I'll talk about the subject for
45 it's fine and oh wait someone else
wants to cover that top of cool
I don't care let's do it whatever you
want to do yeah or the it'd be easier
for these guys that they did it this way
but it can affect you a little bit cool
I don't care okay yeah what about the
ball either for them do it no factors
okay
yeah there's a great attitude to have
great attitude to have man it makes your
life you see I mean think about if you
impose that or not impose it but if
think of you utilize that with your wife
right gotta be careful though your tone
and there's also there's also trapping
we're getting real specific into
domestic scenarios unfolding yes this
will make my wife mad yeah what do you
want for dinner don't care that actually
my wife doesn't like dunya you know so
what do I want for dinner well steak
girl let's go to a steak house yeah
that's cool and then she can she can
lead by negation right no I don't want
take cool let's go get something else
right yeah yeah it's well it seems like
don't care
saying that or in being like that is
different if someone really wants a net
actual answer from you you know there's
got to be a better way to phrase it
in a domestic scenario so I think the
way you phrase it in a domestic scenario
is right here that sounds good yeah
think about that
I know but doing it what mentally same
attitude many think do you want to watch
this rom-com tonight I don't care what
we watched as long as I'm with you yeah
that's good but I don't have to say it's
better is that sounds good yeah yeah
that's good might not buy it on the
wrong let's go domestic scenario I'm
gonna I'm gonna say that's good there no
sounds that sounds good because hey do
you want to go out to the foo-foo new
Italian restaurant sounds good
just think of that right there look you
might not even eat because you're not
gonna go out you're not gonna go out and
say hey I want to get a can you just
inject me with diabetes right now with a
plate of pasta but you're not thinking
that but you know what
what is it worth because the reality is
order the chicken parmesan and don't eat
the pasta what he borderline but we're
still good we're still in there were
still like maintaining yeah well sitting
close to home right now again the I
don't cuz technically it fundamentally
goes against pretty much anything well
in my situation that my wife even lives
for like the whole idea I don't care
you gotta care that's that's why sounds
good yeah yeah that sounds good yeah
yeah yeah that's correct but it's the
same attitude but you keep that you know
you can't that under wraps
echo Charles yes sir yes hey that sounds
good hey do you what is she oh yeah
doesn't your wife likes to watch reality
television from time to time right so
when she says hey hon Real Housewives of
Orange County seven is on my man
mm-hmm do you want to watch it that
sounds good yeah there you go well see
you do play the game a little bit yeah
yeah okay cool good good tip check next
section know what is important and what
isn't one of the things that
distinguishes a black belt in jujitsu
from a white belt is the black belts
understanding of what is important what
isn't a black belt sees past
insignificant movements ignores trivial
actions and focuses on what actually
matters a good commander on the
battlefield does the same thing the
commander can tell when the enemy is
shooting when the enemy shooting is
merely reconnaissance by fire a good
commander understands when the enemy
movement is just deployed a good
commander ignores things that will not
have any impact on the battle like the
black belt and the battlefield commander
any good leader must be able to do the
same thing discriminate between what is
important and what is not for a leader
in any situation changes are everywhere
both external and internal external
changes can occur in the environment the
behavior of the enemy the market the
weather or the timing of a scenario
internal changes can be emotions of
individuals relationship dynamics or the
morale of the team change is the reality
of life almost everything is in constant
state of flux and it is crucial it is a
crucial part of the leaders job to
figure out which changes are important
in which changes are mere distractions
this is not always easy to do
I see leaders get caught up in all the
time and things that do not matter they
waste their time and energy on
meaningless events or minor problems
that will not impact the overall results
they are trying to achieve a black belt
in jujitsu is a master of energy
conservation not one movement is wasted
defending against attacks that do not
matter leaders must do the same thing
try to give a little insight on how to
actually do this a good leader detaches
and elevates above the tactical
situation where they can see what really
matters before they dive into a problem
they ask themselves questions how will
this problem impact the team's strategic
goals can it cause mission failure is it
worth my time and effort to engage in
how bad can it get if I leave it alone
the answers to such questions should
make it obvious to a leader if a problem
requires their involvement a good rule
to follow is that the leader should err
on the side of not getting involved in
problems the goal is always to allow
problems to get solved at the lowest
level when subordinates are so solving
low-level problems it allows the leader
to focus on more important strategic
issues so there you go and of course
there's a dichotomy with that because if
you become too detached and you don't
pay attention any problems you can have
some issues yeah the next section is
called principles and again we're
getting more and more granular like as
each section goes by talk about who's
the most important team member in a team
yeah just we've said it already but just
kind of revisiting this is all under
strategy these are all the the frame of
minds there's all the the mindsets you
as a leader should have for all these
things
this isn't prescriptive in every single
situation there is an economy with
everything and and there are
circumstances which will drive you to be
heavily involved in things but it's the
mindset of how do I want to view my role
as a leader as it applied that's the
stretch strategic part of this and why
it fits in there and that's why if you
don't know and you're looking for a
place to bias bias in that direction
doesn't mean 100% of the time there that
isn't the answer all the time and this
isn't the tactical solution of what's
going on it's how you should perceive
your role as a leader and what your bias
should be and then the tactical
situation might change and you might
need to get more or less involved and do
a whole bunch of different things and
that certainly comes later
but that mindset and we kept saying
frame of mind from the beginning is
crucial to understanding why this sits
in the book the way it does even
shooting a 240 gulf or the bipod there
are times when you are going
to whatever you are going to get that
thing off the bipod you you there
there's things that you're gonna do you
have to understand that that's what the
strict what the strategy is and then yes
absolutely right you have to use your
brain yeah fortunately the more you
understand the strategies and the more
tactics you know and understand the more
effectively you can use your brain to
overcome some of these scenarios that
unfold in the real world yeah
the lower down in the organization the
more tactical the behaviors of those
people are and to the point that
sometimes you might have a machine
gunner that really doesn't understand
much of the big picture at all but when
you have the times to go down there
after they've made some tactical
decision especially if it's a good
tactical decision and you can explain
hey what you did made a huge impact
upstream of the organization you made a
massive help support for the larger
strategic goal when you can make the
connection for them and they recognize
how what they're doing this tiny little
task that seems almost menial or small
actually makes a contribute to the big
picture
how powerful that is to be able to
continue to be more and more and more
detached and they continue to do things
without your help because they know what
they're doing and how it affects the
connections in their tactics and the
strategy your ability to explain that
makes huge headway with them so we get
into section three and again talking
about the most important team member
talk about span of control so people
understand what the best way is to do
that talk about taking care of your
people with discipline discipline is the
best way to take care of your people
from day one as a leader in the military
you're told over and over again
you have to take care of your people but
some leaders get confused about what
that means they think taking care of
your people means making sure they are
comfortable and happy coddling them
giving them as much time off as possible
and not pushing them hard this is wrong
in fact the opposite is true in the SEAL
Teams if you really care about your
people you won't coddle them at all you
will push them hard you will train them
hard you will make sure they understand
the tactics of war and the weapons and
radios they will operate you will ensure
they are in top physical condition and
prepared for the mental and emotional
stress of combat you'll do everything in
your power
them for combat so they can so they so
you can give them the highest
probability that they and the rest of
the team returned from the battlefield
if you really care about your people you
want them to go home to your to their
families the best way to make that
happen is to hard training that comes
from discipline the same thing is true
in business while lives might not be on
the line if you really want to take care
of your people you need to push them you
need to make sure they understand their
jobs you need to drive them toward their
goals if they fail professionally they
failed to achieve their financial goals
goals and they cannot take care of their
families or provide for them the way
they want to so when you are a leader
the best thing you could do is push them
toward their goals and of course this
drive has to be balanced and then the
reason I kind of had to put that in
there cuz I wanted to go a little bit
deeper on imposed discipline because I
say over and over again that discipline
shouldn't be imposed on people and it
usually has a bad outcome or least has a
negative taste it leaves a negative
taste in people's mouths when you impose
discipline on them so going back to the
book optimal discipline in a team is not
imposed by the leader it is chosen by
the team itself optimal optimal
discipline is self discipline but teams
do not always have self discipline they
may not understand the rewards that come
with it when that happens it may be
necessary for a certain level of
discipline to be carefully applied and
imposed so the team understands the
benefits and I kind of go through how
you do that how do you impose that
discipline without leaving a bad taste
in everyone's mouth yeah good
methodology it's also a good way this
kind of leads into the next topic which
is pride because pride is about is a
powerful force when when people have
pride it can change an organization
going back to the book if there is pride
the team police's itself the team will
not allow substandard performance anyone
who slacks off is corrected not by the
leadership but by the team itself that
is the power of pride what then of a
team
lacks pride perhaps it doesn't have a
storied history perhaps it doesn't have
a history of victory to old high what
then it is one of the most critical
tasks as a leader to instill pride in
your team how do you do that
how can you build the morale of troops
and create the strong bonds of pride
that result in an attitude where
everyone on the team gives more than
what is required because that's the
truth right there right you have a team
that has pride they're given more and
their self policing you have a team that
doesn't have pride they're given the
minimum in the minimum the self policing
part of that is is so powerful when you
don't need to impose any correction on
your team simply because they care
enough to do with themselves yeah yeah
as I've talked about on this podcast
before the amount of times that I had to
talk to a guy in task unit bruiser
because they were late is zero right it
was guys late yeah but it never made it
to me right they were getting tightened
up all the front lines right oh guy
doesn't have his gear squared away cool
that evening I was down there counseling
that person no they were getting
tightened up old school they were not
gonna make that mistake again
why pride so how do you get how do you
how do you establish pride back to the
book the answer simple you give them the
opportunity to earn it pride does not
develop simply by telling team members
that they are great or by hanging up
banners all the banners and signs and
flags mean nothing if they aren't earned
to build pride within a team you have to
put the members in situations that
require unity strength and perseverance
to get through you have to push them in
training to a point where they are truly
tested and in that they will develop
pride in what they have accomplished
skipping forward to another section here
it's called yes-men as a leader you
should not want to be surrounded by yes
men people who agree with everything you
say as a subordinate you should not be a
yes-man so this is like the counter to
the whole initial part of this
conversation talking about hey boss yes
I got this yep boss I got that yep you
want me to do that extra paperwork yep
you want to cover there yeah that's
that's totally true and here we go in
the other direction as a subordinate you
should not be a yes-man you should speak
up when something doesn't make sense
this concept sometimes worries leaders
because essentially what I am saying
here is that subordinates should always
be pushing back against their leaders
always asking their leaders why things
are being done a certain way and always
offering up information and
recommendations from their perspective
on the front line that scares some
leaders some leaders would rather just
have their subordinates do exactly what
they are told to do but that is a bad
idea so I get this all the time that
makes people nervous but the problem is
when you're surrounded by yes men it's
your brain against the world and your
brain is not strong enough you're gonna
make bad plans bad decisions and if all
you have is a bunch of people that say
yes boss you're right you're gonna end
up in a bad situation
yeah and leaders who aren't surrounded
by yes men who start about people who
are willing to push back worst case
scenario for them is things don't go
well they regroup they come up with us
to solve the problem they move forward
they might have some bats and back and
forth but it's not catastrophic you're
surrounded by yes men when you finally
fail again it will it's it's gonna be
catastrophic because there'll be nobody
there left to help figure out what it is
that you need to do so their recognition
to is a leader that if you actually
really care about winning which a lot of
times drives the ego the worst way to do
it is surround yourself by by yes
because when you fail you'll fail
catastrophically and you don't have that
in organizations where people push back
which is that's the fear like I don't I
don't want people pushing back against
my plants cuz I think I might look dumb
actually you do because what you really
want to do is be successful
and that catastrophic failure is what
you see with companies and teams where
everybody just whatever you want boss
wherever you say boss you know in a way
that's not constructive but just
whatever they wanted here to just kind
of move past it the failures they see it
was when companies they lose everything
do not surround yourself with yes-men
and that means don't be one now this
doesn't mean that you form bad
relationships with your boss and I'm
actually in the book like explain how to
do that what does this sound like so
you'll have the ability to speak
properly and not develop an antagonistic
relationship with your boss can get that
in the book you know one more little
section here for this part of the book
for the strategy part the exception to
know bad teams only bad leaders in
extreme ownership we wrote that there
were no bad teams only bad leaders we
were not the first people to make this
claim Napoleon said there were no bad
regiments only bad Colonels and u.s.
army colonel david hackworth said in his
book about face that there were no bad
units only bad officers yet there are
still people who feel that a bad team is
a legitimate excuse for bad performance
this is simply not true there are no
situations and no exceptions where a
subordinate is ultimately responsible
for the performance of a team it is
always the leaders fault
and hey imagine what I went through to
write that sentence that's a bold
sentence there are no situations and no
exceptions where a subordinate is
ultimately responsible for the
performance of a team it is always the
leaders fault
I believe me I racked my brain hopefully
maybe someone will come up with an
example where that's wrong I haven't
figured one out yet going on that being
said there is an exception to the rule
that there are no bad teams only bad
leaders the exception is that it is
possible to have a good team that
delivers outstanding performance despite
a bad leader how does that happen if
leadership is the most important thing
in the success or failure of a team it
happens when there are subordinates in
the team who lead regardless of their
rank
they are tactful individuals who know
how to lead despite not having been
given official authority and this is
what you've been talking about a bit
today Dave already which is look you can
have a bad leader and those team is good
and they want to get the job done and
they believe in the mission and they
will win despite bad leadership despite
bad leadership all right so we're
approaching we're approaching three
hours I think right now and we just
finished so that that good place to take
a break and we will get back so we
finished this strategy part of
leadership strategy and tactics and on
the next podcast we will cover part 2
leadership tactics in the meantime I
guess if you like listening to us I'm
gonna be talking some more add some live
events around the country cool does that
sound like a tour yes the classic it's a
classic example of what not to do what
did I do
I said hey what hey we're not a rock
band we're not going on tour and guess
what I'm doing now going on to work kind
of doing some live gigs January 6 in DC
January 11th in Austin
January 16th in New York January 20th in
LA January 27th in Seattle and January
28th and SF some of the gigs already
sold out go to Jocko live.com if you if
you want to come and get engaged
it's called decisive engagement that's
the name of the event they do decisive
engagement yeah the events the tour
tours the decisive engagement tour
yeah straight down so I will be talking
and I will be answering questions
meeting with you looking forward to it
get into those cities and hanging out
with y'all and what else we talked a
bunch about leadership today mm-hmm yeah
what about leading ourselves is there
anything you know what can we do to lead
ourselves in many things a lot of
not a lot but some jiu-jitsu references
yeah in the old leadership strategy once
again amazing how jujitsu is a thread
that has runs through everything
jiu-jitsu this life so participate in
life frightened so yes you're joining
jiu-jitsu we're doing jiu-jitsu still
people everyday daily semi daily twice
daily sometimes people saying hey I am
either thinking about it or I just
joined mmm when you join you're gonna
need again this is less of a question by
the way because we all know this so
we're gonna get an origin key get it
from origin man calm brash cards as well
for noogie
there you go boom Jiu Jitsu that's one
thing is wearing jeans a way to get
better I will say this if you're wearing
jeans that a are get allow you complete
freedom of movement right that's one
thing we try to do to the enemy in a war
we try and limit their freedom of
movement yes and you did too by the way
the jiu-jitsu we try and limit our
opponents freedom of movement so why
would you actually voluntarily put on a
garment that restricts your freedom of
movement you don't want to do that
that's why you're getting origin genes
which have stretch in them so you know
you can't tell from looking at it's not
like you look at them you go all those
are kind of some high fashion thing no
they look like a pair of work jeans but
guess what you're fully mobile you're
not pinned down slight fashions no when
when you're wearing them you don't you
know I'm just saying you kinda can smell
some fashion on them depends on who's
wearing them me okay yeah but you kind
of stink of fashion one my my lovely
wife is giving me a thorough evaluation
of my aesthetic value at any given time
while wearing these origin jeans the
fashion element is prevalent mmm well
good I'm glad you like that but to
answer your question because I wasn't
talking about fashion I was talking
about function functionally yes we're
good to go this is a positive thing this
is a positive thing in your life
on top of that why not doing some why
not do something where you are actually
helping the country that you live in
become a better place yeah that's true
why would you not do that why would you
not support the very country that
provides you with the freedom to move so
you get a pair of jeans that give you
the freedom to move and then and then
you support the nation that provides you
with that freedom to move the freedom to
do jujitsu I'm gonna come to that goes
defense just a little bit thank you
because you guys both know I can't give
away my source but I might already have
those jeans you're talking about with
that little stretch little Moby I'll
have that little mobility yeah I got a I
got a little Vance you got Delta 68 yes
okay check sorry oh that's cool I got
all right no and you guys both know I
don't do jeans I do shorts and basically
99% of the time I think I gave the
caveat was well if I ever got a pair of
jeans I ever wanted to wear maybe I'd
wear jeans hold they showed up I put
them on my wife who I don't know the
last I honestly do not know the last
time she's seen me wear a pair of jeans
it is years she said dang those look
good the fashion but the first words out
of her mouth were those look good yeah
undeniable fashion undeniable I mean a
difference between they look sharp and
fashion yeah you don't you got triggered
by the fashion word yeah I say sit sorry
sorry hey that actually that's saying a
lot Dave Berg mean or Dave Burke came
shooting at the gun range with me mmm
straight-up shorts flip-flops so that
that I can confirm that whole notion
that he does not wear jeans and shorts
and flip-flops are his mean which is a
modus mode situation unless yes that is
true about the jeans I don't have the
Delta 68 mm-hmm usually you should be
getting up soon they're they're in
production but actually they're live
right now by the time this podcast come
out well that's it I'm just saying Dave
Haslam yeah yeah yeah you know you
should do build better relationships in
people
because apparently someone's winning
over their lockers relationships and
he's not doing it and it's not doing it
so he can get genes that happens to be a
byproduct yeah okay we're talking about
the Delta 68 genes are the light weight
genes there's there's reg there's
regular genes which is like when I go to
Montana I wear the regular jeans when I
am in Southern California or the more
temperate regions of America and
actually most of the time it's the Delta
68 light weight jeans right it's good
and I look forward to that brain Pete oh
you got weight would that be Pete yes
that would be Pete both you guys just
just sight note or somebody over to that
really a real player would know the
people in the front right and for you
echo just as you're as you're looking
projecting down the road of your
relationship building yes when things
show up unrequested or unsolicited that
means your window these to me you're not
winning as much as when like wow thank
you very much for this ya know what's
interesting is I mean what's interesting
is when is the last time you just
shipped a nice little box of you know
choco podcast t-shirts out to Pete yeah
it's true you know Sam yes he's looking
at you like you know yeah we don't even
have it relations okay wait
quid pro quo here yeah all right
there you go a these are all good tips
am learning mmm Jack you ever you ever
find people when people say ham I mean
I'm learning you know like almost like
it's like almost like a cop-out for
their bad behavior I'm still I didn't
have really thought about but I just
kind of felt that anyway jeans are they
are awesome regardless of my
relationship or lack thereof and with
Pete and Brian and everyone at war gym
speaking of supplementation we also have
supplementation at origin and actually
speaking of triggered Dave Burke mister
you know hey try and keep it clean and
professional in one of the outtakes was
describing how much he liked strawberry
milk and he dropped an F
yeah I mean like a full flat I did with
authority and passion well for the
people who know me and how almost never
I say that work certainly public's I
think that just indicates how much I
still like strawberry yeah and you only
mix it with milk strawberry milk and
shake it up and you're good that's it I
hear all these stories have always
concoctions every still it's Mulk and
milk in a cup and you just it's like
every time the f-bomb just because I
made one the other day and this was all
there's a little violation here whatever
I'm gonna I'm coming clean to a world so
I had you ever eat dinner and you're
like you know what not only was it not
satisfying in volume
it was also unsatisfying in taste right
and I'm not gonna call out the person
that executed this thing that I'm
married to but it was not the deal so I
got done and I had like not just a
craving for more food but tasty food
yeah so I made this milk I made I just
rated milk peanut butter Molk Molk
peanut butter milk two scoops of peanut
butter and then two scoops of vanilla
ice cream this thing was ridiculous it
was so good that I shared which is we
did it with a whole nother thing I said
to my son
I said hey a guy you gotta try this oh
that okay and then he cuz normally if
it's if it's just really really good
um this is all mine I hated him I paid
for it I mean I created it it's mine
right you want uua this go get go mix
one this was so good I said no you I
want to give this away this makes a you
know he said when he drank tit oh my god
but you shifted a little bit of
short-term they're a little short term
start with the ice cream man ice cream
yeah yeah yeah just a little bit not too
much though that's kind of the acting I
think well I think what it was was you
just you get that caloric deficit oh
yeah so you're not even just thinking
man that dinner wasn't just didn't have
enough so I'm game crazy so ya got
supplement smoke
sounds like a justification but yeah man
also a jockle white tea mm-hmm you know
in the event of you wanting something
light you know if you're gonna cattle or
ik deficit this this might not help you
in that regard
might not yeah but it might give you a
little kicker it'll give you some kick
there's some caffeine in it yes sir and
will you feel like a food snob and start
looking down on other people when you
get done drinking a jock whitey because
it's certified organic well you start
looking down your nose a little bit at
people potentially yes and say oh I said
that looks like a interesting snack
you're having doesn't look very organic
to me but it is true nonetheless yes
also jock was a story it's called
Jacko's door this is where you can get
sure it's representative of the path
directly representative by the way
discipline equals freedom when I'm
currently wearing good deal Dave good
deal Dave good deal reppin we're
representing big time anyway there's a
lot of good mom does your mom have a
good deal Dave sure totally
does he have 700 she has two I am
representing we gotta make a shirt we
got to make a good deal Dave just for
her that's just got your face on it
so she can just be stoked my mom sent me
a screen capture the other day she got
some sort of thing
apparently Facebook tracks this but when
you comment more than other people you
get a notification that you're a top and
often yeah she is one of your top fans
you got notified that she's a jock Oh
top fan screen capture that sent me this
that says Arlene is a jock oh dude that
is awesome we need that we need a good
deal Dave shirt with and and speaking of
which factually so wins the new Top Gun
come out summer of 2020 oh man okay well
we'll do what's the bet we need to do a
a like a fight recap of it right a
breakdown of it you know so we'll we'll
do that and and what's the what do you
think that when will it be out on like
Netflix where we can like actually watch
it as it's doing it and comment on it
without violating the you know the the
copyright laws well actually no you can
do it whenever well it's long I don't
know if it's in the theater no we need
we need to be able to watch it on a
computer right right here it's called
commentary fair use you can if you're
doing commentary on something or yeah
it's freaking yeah so we're gonna
absolutely 100% we're gonna sit in here
you're gonna go line by line you can
explain stuff I'm asking stupid
questions
yeah I'll be all yeah are you pumped for
it that's a good I am torso for it
absolutely wait what's the worry I
forget if I asked you this were you
really into Top Gun the og bro that's
why that's his entire life right I mean
the movie though you you mean when I was
14 and I slapped top Top Gun did I think
it was cool
no well no I'm asking like more than
that like was that your jam for that was
yes yeah a hundred percent because I
knew like one of my good friends from
when I was little
Eric masters still pilot too by the way
Oh
Air Force Top Gun now is his jam okay
was house it's a VCR doesn't matter what
era sure an Air Force Navy and Marine
Corps if you watch Top Gun that's why
you want to be about naval aviators
right yeah yeah it's good it's good it's
kind of interesting Dave was on the
podcast before and we knew that we
talked through that entire yeah knowing
the entire thing and and just kind FYI
the trajectory of Dave's entire life I'm
kind of fundamentally rooted in the
movie topic oh but I appreciate the
question it's cool you know I understood
I'm trying to build the relationship you
know and Lafe Babin is Navy SEALs
he saw Navy SEALs and it was super fired
up over Navy SEALs yeah I used to watch
Roadhouse a lot so I guess that's the
same deal
I don't know you got to see yourself a
little Patrick Swayze vibe Dalton breath
Dalton I mean in a way but they always
hear the ongoing thing about Dalton they
always tell him oh I thought you'd be
bigger so I couldn't really my whole god
thing was not to be the guy who they
thought would be bigger saying anyway no
less oh yeah
Jaco store ya represent go there Jocko
store calm if you like something yeah
get something also subscribe to the
podcast if you haven't already is this
important maybe maybe not but it is will
say useful useful see in the game right
right um reviews of the podcast that's a
good way to give us a feedback yes sir
on the podcast so you can write hey I
think the support section should be much
longer I don't think I hear you talking
enough about origin genes yeah yeah I
need way more info right that's a lot so
I want to add that to the commentary go
to the review do it go livre and don't
forget we have other podcasts we got a
podcast called the grounded podcast
which Dave Burke has been on it's not
what people expect apparently is it
about jiu-jitsu
kind of is jiu-jitsu about life very
much so yes what is it about then about
everything
yeah but like relaxed version like even
get relaxed fit jeans if you're Regine's
were constrictive I think those skinny
jeans yeah well you can get relaxed fit
right this is the relaxed fit podcast
close jump to occupy so the chaco
podcast is skinny jeans in the ground
uh-oh
relax feel alright I thought that's what
you Shane no not at all are you sure you
know what do you think that's what
you're saying I most certainly will I
suppose you Darko podcast is alone
fatigue is the uniform alright good you
back off through the minute you almost
caught me right there nicely done and we
also have the warrior kid podcast we got
four new episodes are out so check that
out and then there's a warrior soap
Irish Oaks wrench calm or your kids
aidan on a farm and you know what he
learned on a farm he learned that he
needed to make soaps a week that he
could stay clean yeah it's good anyway
YouTube if you want to know what Dave
Burke looks like we have a YouTube
channel video version of this podcast
and yes there are excerpts just in case
you don't want to you know necessarily
or I don't want to say it if you don't
wanna sit through the three four
sometimes five sometimes five and a half
hours of you know whatever we're talking
about I'm not saying that I'm saying
sometimes you know maybe we've got other
stuff to do that day yeah that's all I'm
saying so maybe you can watch some
excerpts on YouTube channel this one
thing also you can get psychological
warfare which is an album which will
help you through moments a weakness also
you can get flipside canvas calm Dakota
Meyer from podcast 1:15 he has a company
we're an American company american-made
graphic representations of the path and
other cool looking stuff so you can
check that out got some books
we've been reviewing leadership strategy
and tactics Field Manual Dave Burke was
the for one of the first people actually
you I think you might have been the
first person to read some semblance of
it I can see by your reactions today
it's approved approved and then there's
the way of the warrior kids series way
the warrior kid one two and three those
are all you know what you can get your
kids on the path right now you can point
them on the path you're not gonna impose
this but you didn't have to it will work
for you get your kids get your nephew
your niece some random kid down the
street get those kids the warrior kid
books it's I the feedback that I get of
the impact that it's having is beyond
comprehension it's awesome then you can
help a kid you can help a kid so much
get them those books if you got a
littler kid get a Mikey in the Dragons
so that when the entire world is
something to be afraid of they learn how
to overcome fear
and then we got extreme ownership and
the dichotomy of leadership which are
the books that I wrote with my brother
late bag but about leadership some of
the principles that we talked about
today these are the fundamental versions
of those the discipline equals freedom
field manual for the adult that needs to
be on the path that needs the reminder
get that and then there's a salon front
which is our leadership consultancy
where we take all these things that we
talk about and we align leaders inside
of organizations don't work together and
win go to a tional on front comm for
details on that EF online what about if
I mind if one of the most common
questions we get with those companies
we're working with is what do we do when
we're not with them how do we continue
to do this it's really the question is
how do we get reps leadership is a skill
it requires reps after reps after reps
and one of the best ways is EF online
because you can get all the reps you
want with you and your team EF
online.com it is online training which
sounds a week I need to come up with a
better name for it right but it is not
week when you do it I thought it was
gonna be week when we first came up with
the ideas like okay well we'll just kind
of suffer through some weak technology
and but no it's not it's totally legit
its interactive you actually have to
answer questions you have to actually
make decisions so EF online.com
we got the muster leadership seminars
events conventions that the entire
Ashland front team executes to go to
extreme owner shop ownership calm for
details
monster 2020 this is where we're gonna
be we are going to be in Orlando we are
going to be in Dallas and we are going
to be in Phoenix Arizona so if you want
to come to one of those monsters that's
what we're doing there's only three a
year we're not gonna go to whatever
random town you live in
you're gonna have to come to us because
we're not a rock band and we're not on
tour
I am going on a tour yeah you yes you
are and and then we have EF overwatch
and EF Legion Dave EF over watching EF
Legion what do you think
dude what what Mike Cirelli is doing
with that and I told you about a common
question we get the other common
question is I want more people in my
organization that are gonna be on the
path and in the game what can I do to do
that and for your if you're in the
military looking for a way to do
something that contributes every bit as
much as it did in uniform there's a way
to do that there are companies out there
that need people like you right now they
need you and for the companies that
don't know where those people are they
actually all intersect in the same place
they intersect right there at ed and
what Mike's really built with with
overwatch and Legion is where those
people are to connect the people that
need them people where they want to be
it is unreal how much that is is
exploding and recognition how important
that is man it's awesome and we're doing
some things with EF Legion to EF Legion
if you're a vet or you're in right now
and you think you're ever gonna have
some other kind of job or you're ever
going to get out of the military which
you are I hate to tell you go to EF
Legion calm right now and get yourself
enrolled in the system we're offering
we're gonna be offering webinars on how
to like make that transition you're
gonna have you're gonna be able to other
companies are gonna be able to look at
you as a candidate they're gonna be able
to see you
and you're gonna be able to see what
they're looking for so go to EF Legion
comm for that so Legion and if you still
want to hear from us after however many
hours we've been talking then we are all
available on the interwebs on Twitter on
Instagram and on that face
dave is at David R Burke echo is at Echo
Charles and I am at Jocko will Inc and
to all those military folks out there
that are holding the line currently and
when I say currently I mean right now
right this moment in time
there are folks out there holding the
line and protecting freedom and
democracy for us so to all of you right
now thank you for what you're doing same
thing here at home we got police and law
enforcement and firefighters and
paramedics and EMTs and dispatchers and
correctional officers and Border Patrol
and Secret Service and all those first
responders same thing holding the line
protecting us here on the home front
and last thing to everybody this is a
book about leadership and guess what
everyone is a leader you're leading your
team you're leading your family you're
leading your friends that's what you're
doing so pay attention to what you're
doing get the right frame of mind and
then take that frame of mind and go out
there and get after it and until next
time this is Dave Burke adecco and Jocko
out